[Musique]
jean luc mélenchon bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinker view nous sommes
en direct pour la partie 2 est ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succinctement
ceux qui n'ont pas vu pour la ce qui me
pas vu la partie je m'appelle jean luc
mélenchon et je suis député des bouches
du rhône
candidat aux élections présidentielles
et puis quoi encore
j'ai 70 ans
ça va
autant qu on vous reçoit pour la partie
de notre interview parce que vous étiez
attendu la dernière fois et puis on a
profité avec la durée 2 heures quand
même la dernière fois c'était court
on prend notre temps ici on aime bien
délayer les choses donc bienvenu pour la
partie 2 on va parler géopolitique mois
par les finances on a parlé de tout un
tas de trucs
première question votre programme
vous allez bien bossé la partie
économique voulait bien poussé moi j'ai
une question à vous poser c'est est-ce
que vous allez utiliser la même chose
que les banques font c'est à dire les
stress tests est ce que vous avez fait
des stress tests sur votre programme
alors déjà c'est quoi un stress test et
c'est quoi un stress tests bancaires
c'est pour voir si sa liste à certaines
hypothèses
non c'était déjà en bouleau gigantesque
affaire que derrière les chiffres et
parce qu'on voit pas les moyens du
gouvernement même si il ya des garçons
et des filles insoumis un peu partout
qui nous aide mais il fallait quand même
avoir
une référence un référentiel on va dire
pourquoi parce que
tous les modèles économiques où tout le
discours économique c'est un discours
sur la politique de l'offre la politique
de l'offre c'est génial et pas besoin de
réfléchir
on produit n'importe quoi n'importe
commandes du moment que c'est le moins
cher possible à la sortie et à l'entrée
donc on externalise tous les cookies
sont pas directement liées à la
production de sa cage la nature ça
compte pas tu bouzy les gens qui au
travail ça compte pas non plus personne
compte de rien et ça se voit dans toute
la discussion politique vous êtes venu à
maintenant pour moi un petit jeu comme
trop brusque quelque chose commence par
me dire à combien ça coûte alors moi je
commence par dire et pas le faire ça
coûte combien alors là tu as plus de
réponses les plus personne combien ça
coûte deux de ceux-ci combien ça coûte
la malbouffe de parts et et la mal
bouffe etc je réponds 50 milliards donc
une fois qu'on avait l'important pour
nous c'était d'avoir les chiffres pour
évaluer les les le prix de ce conte de
ce que vous prévoyez de faire mais pas
seulement ensuite une fois que vous avez
mis
j'ai donné un euro vous y attendiez pas
ça va créer il y a un coefficient
multiplicateur ça donne un euro 3 de
richesses produites sur un euro 3 il ya
18 centimes qui en montrent
un peu plus mais peu importe 18 centimes
qui remonte dans la caisse de l'état
sous forme de taux moyen de tva ensuite
parce que vous avez tout dépenser avec
votre corps vous aider vous achetez un
carambar du coup le marchand de carambar
lui-même vivant fabriquer de trois de
plus et comme ça en effet de propagation
s'est jamais calculé la plupart du temps
donc nous fallait qu'on fasse ça mais si
on s'était amusé à le faire tout seul
d'après des coefficients pour nos
réinventer c'était pas sérieux donc on a
regardé où il y avait des modèles
disponibles on a été chercher les deux
pires le modèle de bercy alors c'est
marrant à chaque fois comment ça se
passe parce que pour bercy c'est les
impôts c'est très mauvais dans leur
modèle économique et puis pour payer un
deuxième modèle c'est celui de la banque
de france alors lui c'est la dette la
dette c'est la cata il faut pas parler
bon bref et on a pris le plus dur pour
nous le modèle de la banque de france et
on la noue en a nourri avec nos chiffres
et s'adonnait à la sortie
tant que ceux ci tant que cela à temps
de cotisation temps de d'emploi bon et
c'est comme ça qu'on a fait le calcul
donc
après il reste une inconnue bon mais
rien que ça pendant je veux juste
souligner que c'est pas une petite chose
que de le faire d'accord et je crois pas
qu'ils aient une seule autre
organisation qui les fait comme on est
très
très tendue on a été confronté vos
chiffres et on a rencontré deux
instituts qui sont très libéraux dont
l'institut montaigne bon lot d'oublier
son nom mais ils ont été plutôt cool
c'est à dire qu'ils ont accepté
d'échanger avec nous et de comparer et
pour nous la bonne surprise c'est que
leurs chiffres étaient meilleurs que les
nôtres dans les résultats donc on était
assez content donc normalement je
pourrai dormir tranquille en disant je
sais comment me prend sauf que je suis
l'auteur d'un livre qui s'appelle à la
conquête du chaos qui date de 1980 c'est
le premier livre que j'ai écrit et deux
dents jeudi et a un problème
en politique c'est que on suppose
toujours que à une cause à correspond en
effet b comme dans un déterminisme
extrêmement linéaire 1 c'est le
d'éterniser simon laplace c'est là
dessus de travail et karl marx alors si
tu sais la position et la vitesse des
encore un instant tu es tu sais où il
sera tous les coups après tous les coûts
avant pas de bol c'est pas vrai pourquoi
parce que le déterminisme idée
probabiliste c'est à dire que il ya 90 %
99% de chances qu en effet à une cause a
correspondu en effet b mais il ya zéro
pouillème que l'on est et quand ces
longs bas c'est donc quoi sinon à 100%
donc moi je sais que je vais pas dormir
tranquille parce que
il ya un côté montée en puissance de
l'application du programme jugé par un
terrain de tromper parce que au début on
dépense mais avant que tu vois revenir
en impôts en cotisations sociales il ya
un petit délai pendant lequel ça va
chauffer pour nous et il peut y avoir
des interventions maléfique dangereuse
contre nous donc on n'est pas sorti
d'affaires juste parce que moins bon
audel juste parce qu'ils ont été
chercher le truc de la banque de france
et que l'on sait faire alors évidemment
il ya le paramètre de la politique et la
politique c'est à quoi va correspondre
un gouvernement comme le nom de l'union
populaire bon ce qui est certain c'est
que ça va pas être une période sans
implication populaire du cas moi je
souhaite cette application populaire
parce que j'ai pu me rendre compte de ce
que ça donnait quand y'en a pas après
1980 bon tout était parfait 1 sauf qu'il
s'est absolument rien passé et nous on
était là persuadé que derrière une
victoire comme celle là il y aurait un
événement du type vous voyez grève
générale 1936 tout ça quoi prise de
conscience ouais mais active des gens
disant oui allez on veut tout de suite
et c'est pas ça qui s'est passé du tout
alors c'est en partie de notre faute à
nous les dirigeants de gauche de
l'époque moi j'étais un jeune dirigeant
cadres intermédiaires
j'étais premier secrétaire de la
fédération socialiste de l'essonne donc
j'ai vu comment on penser qu'on a
incarné la conscience que si vous
vouliez faire quelque chose eh bien vous
le demandez à moi est ce que l'on fait
de terrain et moi j'ai voté demander
quelque chose à toi qui sais qu'il a dit
de faire la grève personnes alors que
t'es quoi tu es un anarchiste tu peux
pas attendre les consignes bref on était
extrêmement arrogant pas semer persuadé
qu' on allait tout contrôle et que ça a
été une marche au socialisme en réalité
il ya eu ni marche néo socialisme est
par contre on s'est bougé 4 d'évaluation
un emprunt forcé un contrôle des changes
alors là c'était la totale vous savez
pas à l'âge que vous avez ce que ça fait
un emprunt forcé vous recevez un papier
des gouvernements qui vous dit monsieur
bonjour vous prend de temps et on vous
le rendra bientôt rendu vain mais ne
vous jure ça fait un effet osé mais il
s'en vient pas ils m'ont prendre du fric
de force et le contrôle des changes
pareil c'est à dire que comme d'hab tu
peux tu y penses pas tu crois pas que ça
te concerne alors bon tu as prévu tes
vacances et puis tu habitais sud côté
puis tu ne peux pas partir avec monsieur
pierre du tout vous pouvez pas emmener
plus de temps quoi qu'est ce que vous me
dites de quoi vous mêlez est bon donc on
découvre que c'est que que tout ça alors
je suis en traumatisés de la marche au
socialisme qui n'a pas eu lieu et je
supporte plus c'est pour ça que vous je
vous ai répondu aussi précisément je
supporte plus comme bizarre on va le
faire y a qu'à faire comme si il faut
qu'on moi je veux tout le temps qu'on
m'explique pourquoi on commence par quoi
on continue donc
j'ai une équipe formidable j'ai une
équipe nous constituons une équipe
et ils ont fait à côté du programme
ils ont fait délivrer domaine par
domaine et tenez vous bien il ya même
des plans c'est à dire que domaine par
domaine on dit comment on va s'y prendre
alors moi je passe ma vie actuellement
en campagne
un bon tiers montant consiste à re lire
des livres et des plantes et à écrire
des introductions pour tous ces
documents alors il faut quand même que
les assimile mais je vais vous dire
franchement
je crois que ça me déborde parce que
aujourd'hui on va on m'a dit c'est
écoutez moi j'en peux plus j'ai
l'impression d'être passé ma vie comme
un étudiant à préparer les examens les
rencontrer que les journalistes
tu te fais toujours une idée de leur
niveau de précision tu bosses que vous
fout bon j'en ai marre qu alors
comme dit oui ben c'est normal ils sont
sympas avec moi je dis moi je retiens
plus rien ça me saoule et vous dire ah
bah c'est normal quand on est à mille
cinq cents pages alors
pour vous donner une idée de ce que
c'est que la campagne présidentielle par
rapport à ces histoires de programme il
faut tout savoir ils m'ont fait par
exemple
bfm alors face aux français il ya un
côté sympa tu te laisse attraper puis
c'est vous qui choisissez l'endroit tous
avons choisi puis après tu te retrouves
avec des barges en plus bas qui sait
ils sont pas toujours aussi neutre que
ils ont d'abord dit qu'il n'était et
puis surtout la fois c'était 10 8 m
j'ai dit aux journalistes vous êtes fous
18ème à l'ena il ya cinq thèmes à
l'examen il faut que je m'en tape 18
faut que je sache ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec un couple de jeunes adultes
handicapés ensuite qu'est ce que mon
parcours on va remplacer le glyphosate
après qu'est ce que je vais faire pour
la retraite du gac a pas les cotisations
qu'il faut mais qui cependant est il ya
quelque chose je trouve qu'ils passent
dans la face on interrogeait un candidat
qui est profondément antidémocratique
parce que ça a l'air de dire c'était pas
le super g unit qui c'est tout c'était
pas ce magicien qu'est ce que tu fais là
parce qu'évidemment je me classe à
signer si j'avais seulement un instant
de doute
comme il ya deux sous marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins et quelqu'un qu'il est
dieu fait celle-là c'est fou quand tu es
le savoir il avait demandé sa ségolène
royal était sympa parce qu'elle aurait
pu dire au garden et gercées rien puis
d'ailleurs je m'en fous elle aurait pu
dire ça je tiens oui mais vous voulez
être président de la république et ne
sais pas combien de sous marins
et alors on finira bien par me le dire
si c'est moi la présidente de la
république j'aurais 10 à sa place
maintenant je dis ça mais enfin voilà
donc vous m'avez demandé si
j'ai fait d'aider des tests de stress
c'est à dire 2 est-ce que ce programme
peut se rompre comme toute affaire
humaine je sais pas moi on va prendre un
exemple j'apprends 2 de catastrophe qui
peut m'arriver
là on est déjà en état de sécheresse
hivernale dans plusieurs départements
comment tu peux prévoir un truc pareil
bon alors sécheresse hivernale rapport
monsieur mélenchon y ça manque de flotte
on va acheter ailleurs art est très bien
et si tu peux tu peux pas acheter
ailleurs exemple tu veux acheter du blé
mais tu peux pas parce que l'ukraine
c'est la guerre un deuxième problème
troisième problème on dit bon ben c'est
pas grave on va tous manger du pop-corn
savane ou blu ray va prendre le maïs
faire des petits pop corn allez hop
alors on va mettre tout ça dans un truc
électrique bon très bien ah oui mes
problèmes d'électricité à l'appartement
il y en a pas on n'a pas les centrales
nucléaires partout à buea marche pas
dans quoi elle marche pas parce que la
flotte à baisser dans les rivières et
parce qu'elle est chaude donc si tu
prends la flotte pour refroidir la
centrale nucléaire en tulle affreux dit
pas et 2 tu leur envoie encore plus
chaude je blague parce que je prends des
choses qu on attend que ça
je vois que vous écrivez des affaires
ouais je suis assez inquiet de crise se
passait là-bas enfin c'est pour dire qu'
il n'y a jamais eu aucun programme du
monde qui qui garantit de se dérouler là
sauf si vous dites bas ont pas nous
attendent et on va rien changer on va
voir si un problème là il ya un trou
dans la dans l'art dans le plus beau
meeting et puis voilà ayé un deuxième
tour 22e routine hmmm ça reste un peu
voilà on va pas discuter de savoir s'il
faut des bleus ou pas donc pour ceux qui
tiennent l'ordre du monde comme il est à
la limite ils peuvent faire des affaires
c'est ce qu'il faut en ce moment je
donne un exemple
alors il ya la guerre d'ukraine c'est la
catastrophe
tout ça le pétrole russe évidemment il
est criminel le gall qui sent mauvais le
crime donc heureusement et oncle sam qui
vient qui dit euh vous inquiétez pas où
vous pouvez arrêter j'en ai c'est moi
qui vous le vend d'accord ils vont
augmenter de 70% ses livraisons donc
vous à l'heure des milliers de bateaux
qui ont trimballé du gaz et du pétrole
après avec comment ils l'ont fait suit
la cdu du gaz et du pétrole de schiste
chez nous c'est interdit de faire ça
parce qu'on considère que ces deux
l'écocide de faire des tours dans la
terre comme ça en percutant avec la
flotte
c'est horrible quoi horrible pourquoi
parce que ça prouvera que ddd ondes
sismiques bon sens sans fouille est
capable d'onde on fait un trop bon bah
hockey des fois ça perd trop profond
tout ça va être directement après
hâtivement faire attention justement
faut pas attention à eux c'est bien
qu'il ya des gens il ouvre le robinet tu
allumes total umt et clope souffre sur
du feu du robinet parce que mon tout est
pourri par l'armée chance donc vous
voyez le mot la complexité du monde et
effet il déconne
personne ne pourra jamais prétendre le
dominer à 100% et moi je me dis
il faut présidé ce pays
ça va pas être simple de régler tout ça
à la fois mais en même temps on sait ce
qu'on a décidé qu'on allait faire
j'ai un ami qui l'écrit indique un qui
s'appelle introduction ou siècle des
menaces au siècle des menaces
c'est jacques blamont qui a écrit ça
fondateur du programme spatial français
il est décédé en 2019 moi je vais vous
poser une question pour vous quelles
sont les menaces que vous avez identifié
ou
dans les abysses et que des menaces
d'ailleurs ce n'est une ça finit mal
tout le monde meurt donc dans les
cercles que j'allais c'est ma brève
réaction c'est ça c'est quand même bien
c'est la peur aujourd'hui est devenu le
principal union sociale oeuvrant contre
un dirigeant qui écoule de quoi il vous
parle des raisons pour lesquelles faut
avoir peur et de lui faire confiance bon
alors là c'est sip alors après
réfléchissons à vous dire ce n'est pas
une blague il commence par dire ça finit
mal par tout le monde que tu meurs
mais depuis que le monde est monde était
petite troupe de bandes humaines sont
répartis sur la surface de la planète et
si c'est que désormais devant tout le
temps donc les légendes et qu'ils
avaient moyens de s'arrêter départ tu
vois puis surtout bobo que plus rien ne
bouge alors ça tombait bien les
meilleurs des cas c'était quand il y
avait les bestiaux qui passaient
régulièrement une fois par an des
migrations des reines des machins des
trucs des buzz que tu as était parfait
d'un petit abri dans les rochers
parfaitement bien organisée ton petit
feu et puis voilà alors avec ça ça
marche elle reste du temps que des
ennuis c'est parce que tu as eu beau
faire bakhan y avait des gens malades et
puis alors surtout ça a commencé tout de
suite et les trouvailles bizarre alors
monde aborde à un chien qui est venu
l'été domestiquer après les chiens on
est passé à autre chose le chien ça
allait encore il était sympa il était là
et a mis les moutons qu'après 10 et
balazs donc ça ça commence les premières
villes ces 4500 ans avant notre ère
celle qu'on connaît tiens d'ailleurs
pendant que j'y suis
la plus vieille des plus vieilles villes
du monde ça va vous paraître bizarre de
vidéos et sons sur qui vire en ukraine
ma parole moi aussi j'étais comme
bouchons ni des plus vieilles villes
c'est là bas côté irak tout ça non en
ukraine bon dès qu'ils ont commencé à
mettre des bêtes ensemble catastrophe
personne ne sachant d'où ça venait tout
le monde est tombé malade
en grand nombre sont morts
et puis bon après il se sont auto
immunisés ok là dessus il y avait des
types qui passait c'était d'autres dans
de nomades comme effet de passer
ailleurs parce qu'il passait n'était pas
immunisé donc rupture on était mort
alors donc le principal endroit d'où
venait le problème est de venir
maintenant le principal endroit où se
trouvait pour en être en quelque sorte
indemne tout ça c'est pour dire que je
sais pas à qui à l'époque aurait pu dire
ah mais attendez moi je vais vous dire
de quoi on va se protéger alors vous
enlevez les animaux domestiques
vous arrêtez de faire de la culture sur
toute cette connerie de blé qui est là
le lol la plante qui est la moins
intéressante pour la nourriture des
êtres humains qui consomment le plus de
flotte enfin bon bref je pense que
devant nous
on a comme ça les problèmes du 21e
siècle c'est notamment bas c'est pour
dire ses problèmes aussi vieux que
l'humanité des zones ça c'est vraiment
le truc personne n'en sait rien et
encore 1500 virus disponible pour passer
des animaux domestiques des animaux
sauvages aux animaux domestiques va pas
s'arrêter parce que comme vous le savez
le capitalisme c'est un système fabuleux
il se nourrit des désastres qui provoque
alors et fait toujours des sous avec
tous
destruction créatrice et non non ça
c'est des histoires ça ça c'est des
histoires d'économistes tu as qui
descend bas pour faire ses courses que
j'ai jamais vu un poids ou ailleurs que
dans un sac
ou non ces histoires là les destructions
créatrices et quand on a inventé quelque
chose qui détruit quelque chose d'autre
a plus besoin mais dans la vie ordinaire
non ça se passe pas comme ça est bon
pourquoi j ça parce que les zones aussi
le sujet aujourd'hui après la qu'ovide
d'accord donc tu dis bon ça y est comme
cette fois ci l'ont au moins compris ça
rien du tout ça continue comme avant et
c'est pas tout on a une on peut dire
écoutez vous avez vous la barre vous
n'arrêtez pas de donner des conseils
mais vous êtes quand même
particulièrement nul c'est vous qui nous
donnait des conseils d'accord et il ya
eu dans ce pays une épidémie de grippe
aviaire il est au courant de monsieur
oui vous avez bien croisé du noir vous
achetez une patte de lapin et un fer à
cheval comme ça le microbe le pape a
cédé à la volaille à nous parce que la
volaille a plus que ça dans ce monde 80%
des oiseaux qui se baladent c'est de la
volaille d'élevage il balade pas
de pouvoir première crise despallières
tu te disons compris et ben oui il ya
d'ailleurs une deuxième vague de grippe
aviaire ils ont tellement bien compris
quand une troisième là dessus tu
t'attends ce qu'on a au moins un qui
lisent attendez on va pas recommencer
tous les trois ans un a tué des millions
voyais comme ça juste pour parce qu'on a
peur à l'export s'est même pas que ça
soit à contaminants troisième l'accord
et bien non il y en a une quatrième élan
ce moment c'est la cinquième ça fait
cinq fois qu'il ya une épidémie de
grippe aviaire on tue tous les bestiaux
à chaque fois et qu'est ce qu'on a fait
pour régler le problème zéro rien la
chance qu'on a c'est que le virus ait
pas passer aux ordres vous êtres humains
parce que relation petit peu alors
comment voulez vous que je vous dise moi
pauvre mélenchon que je suis dans mon
coin combien de ces inventions là et
vont encore de conduire à des
catastrophes place ce week-end j'en ai
évoqué je vous la raconte quand même
d'abord j'ai réalisé une chose que je
n'ai pas réalisé mais vous êtes malin
peut-être que vous l'aviez vu vous avez
vu que on est riverain avec une crème
qui ai pas pensé c'est en préparant je
me dis mais
un dieu et riverains de tanger à sotchi
c'est la même mère alors elle s'appelle
méditerranée après sa belle mer de
marmara après il ya neuf mille sept
mille cinq cents ans avant notre ère la
mère a bien poussé en trouvant le
bosphore il fallait passer de l'autre
côté la flotte est passé c'est là le
mythe du déluge voyez cet endroit là
alors il ya d'autres hypothèses pour lui
dit non écoutez moi je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'il écrit dans libé ya ya
ya six voire non mais sans blague et
j'ai quand même eu trois quatre trucs le
fond de la mer et de la mer noire et en
effet noir et c'est toutes sortes de
choses la porte ils en ont déduit que
tout ça c'était rempli d'un coup et puis
après ça continue c'est la mer d'azov
pas la mer caspienne elle est sur le
côté y'a pas de dire mais là il ya un
lien donc de tanger à sotchi dans le
caucase
tout le monde est riverain alors il
d'ailleurs ça joue dans notre
civilisation parce que ceux qui aiment
les récits sur la civilisation antique
grecque et romaine
il par exemple mythe de la toison d'or
vous avez entendu parler n'est ce pas eh
bien ça se passe en géorgie et pour un
grec il y avait rien de plus simple que
d'aller en géorgie puis tu passais deux
sortes d'autres côtés quoi ça y est tu
es est d'ailleurs passé là il les avait
c'était pas un endroit simple pour eux
alors donc je réalise à et je réalise
que les centrales nucléaires qui sont en
ukraine elles sont une bonne partie sur
le dniepr que ses affluents qui portent
des noms à coucher dehors et si un
problème c'est pas un truc pour les
russes c'est que c'est pour nous alors
il ya deux raisons pourquoi c'est pour
nous première raison à cause du sens de
la terre et du sens du vent
donc c'est direct on ne s'était pas
l'arrêt à la fois où on irait les nuages
radioactifs ont eu le bon goût de
s'arrêter à la frontière donc on est
tranquille mais c'est pas tous les coûts
qui vont être poli et s'arrêter à la
frontière d'une quête fortes
probabilités pour que ce soit pour mais
pas seulement comme c'est le diable le
nia puis la tique pas au dans la mer
noire et la mer d'azov la merde
donc tout ce qui se mettra sur les
rivières sur les centrales nucléaires
toulon le fleuve est tous dans la
méditerranée et la méditerranée c'est la
même d'un bout à l'autre miss sotchi et
le reste est du pareil au même donc même
situation nucléaire de danger nucléaire
et comme il faut sans temps pour que la
mer méditerranée renouvelle son dos
pour ne s'entendait tranquille après
vous me direz c'est le problème des
poissons dans l'océan
pas plus s'occuper de tout le monde donc
déjà ans s'occupe de nous voilà c'est
pour dire que y'a pas de prise de
conscience de ce problème
j'avais moi j'avais commencé à utiliser
cet argument à l'époque où j'essayais de
lancer l' alerte sur le prêt de
l'ukraine mais bon tout le monde s'en
foutait et continuent à s'en [__] moi
je propose qu'on installe la bande cren
1 parce que les journalistes c'est comme
ça pourquoi vous ne mettez pas dans ta
prise alors monsieur mélenchon qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant concrètement
monsieur mélenchon qui ce qu'on fait
concrètement est valable à ma question
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant concrètement doit
répondre rien comme d'habitude mais bon
non on va essayer de faire quelque chose
moi je propose que on met des casques
bleus qui s'interpose devant et
centrales nucléaires
alors on me dit non mais ça va pas tu te
rends compte le danger je m'excuse mais
des casques bleus anton a mis entre le
hamas et israël alors niveau de tension
ça se compare
donc conviés mais là-bas et casques
bleus c'est leur boulot c'est faire une
force d'interposition
c'est un métier et s'il le fallait et
nous français dont on proposera notre
armée pour faire parce que bleu sous les
ordres de l'onu et
protéger les sites ce qui paraît qu'il
ya nouveau le feu à tchernobyl bon il
faut les gens qu'il n'y a pas de mémoire
pitt le on ne sait pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est l'excitation quand tu penses
de ces infos en continu
sur le sujet que dalle bon mais il n'y a
pas de mémoire les gens devraient dire
tiens je vais aller voir à l'ina pour
trouver comment ça s'est passé le coup
de chaire mobile alors qu'elle parle pas
du déclenchement d'accident
on va oublier parce que le nucléaire
vous comprenez c'est sûr maintenant mais
il faut comprendre ça c'est le
raisonnement de base donc puisque c'est
sûr à quoi bon s'inquiéter
voilà bon là c'est un conte qu'a voulu
voir ce que ça donne quand on pousser la
machine à bout mais la vue à tout a
sauté
quand on me dit les gens croient pas ils
croient pas que c'est un gars qui a fait
c'est une erreur humaine une erreur
humaine three mile island pourquoi il ya
eu un accident ce que le guen avait un
peu de buzz s'ils voyaient pas les
boutons
personne ne croit comme vous le dites
c'est jean rigaud nommé le verrai
mélenchon c'est drôle et ainsi de suite
fukushima tu connais le gars qui a
inventé qui aurait jamais une amie
justement sur la côte où il y en a tout
le temps famous tristesse
230 c'est ça alors donc
tchernobyl quand il a vu l'accident
batta des dizaines d' humilier pauvre
mec qu'on a réquisitionné
je crois qu'il en a que deux c'est ça il
faudra vérifier les chiffres par contre
ce qu'on peut dire s'est il réjoui
à la suite de ça on continue et rennes
les choix qui continue toujours à
envoyer les gamins en vacances
genre un sauna thorium pour se remettre
de leurs émotions longtemps après
attendent km c'est interdit d'y rester
fukushima c'est 80 km
donc tu prends la centrale de nogent
tu piques ton combat dedans tu fais un
gros comme ça
donc quatre heures tu regardes chekade
dans
pas en faire une histoire talus 12
millions de personnes à déplacer
sa pas l'air d'émouvoir si j'augmente le
tout de
d'acceptation de décret de curry de ce
que vous voulez on peut peut-être
diminué à 6 millions
fut le schéma ils ont toujours les
meilleurs attendait maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait que la flotte on n'en sait
rien et quelques semaines dans l'océan
on en est à ce niveau là bon moi je
pensais à la blague parce qu'on veut pas
non plus tout faire que du drame dans ce
qu'on raconte notre question c'est
quelles sont les menaces la dl je vous
parle de trucs qui nous pendent au nez
et vous comment on fait le même constat
ça a pas l'air d empêcher de dormir
moi je vous dis mais qu'est ce que je
fais moi si ça m'arrive je suis
président de la république et une nuée
on me réveille en me disant il ya un
problème
ça comme gros avec la centrale de nogent
qu'est ce que vous avez prévu qu est ce
que vous avez prévu dans ce cas là alors
monsieur le président on voit la sq
centrale de nogent catastrophe alors
petit à nous ouvrons le barrage de lobo
a voilà une bonne idée ouvrons le
barrage zoom et après qu'est ce que vous
faites après eh bien c'est tout comment
ça c'est tout bah oui on ouvre le
barrage de l'aube l'aude lob du barrage
chouf descendant la scène et toute la
clique cafouilla direct dans la manche
au revoir et merci
à un homme attendait 1 pour l'eau c'est
pas pareil pour capter l'eau on arrête
de l'apprendre en scène on la prend dans
la marne
et s'il pleut ce jour là
j'ai pas prévu
après qu'est-ce que les jeudis dans le
débat public moi je me suis retenu
pendant des années nos jours il ya qui
veut affoler qui veut faire peur je vous
raconte une histoire quand il ya eu la
sphère du chernobyl
bon à l'époque j'étais plutôt nucléaire
je trouvais que bon c'est un de gauchy
ça me saoulait et tout le temps peur de
tout l'assurance à technique et tout ça
mais parra qui passe par acquis de
conscience me dit je suis sénateur à
l'époque moi je dois vérifier ce que ce
que je crois donc je fais une lettre et
je demande je pose des questions et on
fait une réponse que je reçois deux mois
après tu vois
quand la réponse est on compare avec la
réponse les deux ans avant et même à
quelqu'un d'autre la même donc je me dis
quand même bon après tu te réveilles tu
dis bon bah c'est normal c'est les mêmes
mêmes causes mêmes effets donc je me dis
bah tiens puisque c'est comme ça je vais
y aller
écrire et nous reçoive super poli super
aimable ou bien voir la centrale de
nogent bon et a valu à qui nous fait la
petite conférence avant c'était un
ingénieur quand même comme je suis pas
tombé de la dernière pluie que l'autre
des questions qui font peur et je
regarde comment le type réagi
physiquement non mais c'est important
c'est un ingénieur un type super
rationnelle et tous à chaque fois que tu
parles et employer le mot 6dans ou que
lui parlé d'incidents qui chope et sa
cravate
pour la remettre en place donc je me
suis dit celui-là il ya un truc qui va
pas bien avec son histoire beau pour ça
parce nous là sur le toit de la centrale
alors garde une belle forêt derrière
alors pour dire qu'elles s'ouvrent mais
vraiment pour dire quelque chose je dis
oh ça doit être sympa sadoine giboyeux
là dedans à l'époque les chats ça
m'intéressait je jamais été chasseur
mais enfin tu vois c'est peu dire
quelque chose
elle via non il n'y a pas de problème et
kribi je lui ai même pas pensé que
pouvoir en prendre acte et biches alors
non le problème c'est les lapins ils
passent ou les grillages une bouffe les
fils
[__] silence tu le sens avec tes
doigts le silence du marbre tu vois du
froid
tout le monde se regarde et moi je
réalise qu'il est en train de me dire le
gaz dit ah bon et on promet des lapins
ici non mais ça y est on a réglé depuis
on a creusé bien profond même riel
beaucoup plus profond je dis pas ça pour
dire qu'ils font pas leur boulot pour me
moquer d'eux je pense qu'ils font leur
boulot très sérieusement et tout mais
c'est pour dire à quoi ça tient les gens
à arrêter de croire que il ya des
solutions 100% garanti d'avant donc la
question que tu dois te poser c'est
qu'est ce que ça donne dans le 1 % au
savoir et dans le vent pour cent ou
savoir c'est la cata à 100% c'est ça
qu'il faut arriver à comprendre
et sans se laisser abattre parce que non
plus repas rien faire à chaque fois mais
on doit intégrer le fait que la décision
humaine ne sera jamais une décision qui
dispose à 100% de la nature et des
choses et des êtres
voilà c'est pas moi cette histoire
qu'elle vient nous raconter permet de
bertheaume est sûr c'est pas beaucoup
plus
quand ça y est j'ai fini avec les
menaces
la liste était correction de fixer et
vous parler du nucléaire
nous on bosse beaucoup sur l'énergie on
bosse beaucoup sur l'accès des
ressources l'accès aux ressources
la question je vais vous poser
concernant le risque nucléaire je pense
que vous avez bien compris qui est quand
même un risque et que ce pouillème de
risque peut entraîner un ciné noir sur
notre économie de traverser la fin bon
nous les français
avec une centrale imagine que ça arrive
par non c'est moi qui vous interromps
mais imaginez qui nous arrive quelque
chose aux gens c'est fini
imaginez qu'il nous arrive quelque chose
dans la vallée du rhône sur une centrale
dans notre mêlée chimiques et donc ça
arrive très sérieux alors moi je vais
vous poser une question différemment les
ce qu'on fait avec avec notre addiction
à l'énergie notre addiction à la calorie
facile je parle de calories parce que
ici on synthétise tout en calories ça va
du verdon ou verre de bière au mode de
production de vos chaussures jusqu'à le
bonbon la vosgienne et on en passe et
des meilleurs donc en termes d'addiction
vous avez en face une technologie qui
marche d'une façon intermittente quand
c'est pas en réparation quand il n'ya
pas de sécheresse ça fonctionne anonyme
c'est comme garant de notre indépendance
à moitié énergétique
comment on fait pour faire passer aux
gens qu'on est des drogués de l'énergie
et que ça va mal se terminer parce qu'on
a une classe politique qui fait de la
cavalerie
en termes d'énergie en termes de
finances et les réalités physiques de
sites où le tout la terre passe au
nucléaire
comment on va faire pour produire les
crayons de combustible avec les gaines
de zirconium et toutes les pénuries
qu'on peut avoir sur les métaux c'est un
autre risque donc la question c'est
comment on fait pour
faire un sevrage énergétique
non mais c'est moins compliqué que ça en
a l'air je peux dire que c'est simple
mais
je trouve qu'il ya d'abord quelque chose
qui est un peu insupportable dans le
regard sur le nucléaire comme s'ils
étaient indépassables bon alors déjà
vous avez pris des précautions de
langage vous êtes mal à dire comme ça
marche comme c'est pas intermittents
auquel moitié des centrales sera l'arrêt
à cause d'eux alors à cause de tout
révision qu'il faut faire deux yeux il y
en a 17 il ya dix-sept réacteurs qui ont
déjà dépassé les 40 ans bon bref y'a
qu'à moitié qui marche en ce moment et
puis alors le couple indépendante sur le
cif lutins parce que non l'uranium y en
a pas en france donc faut aller le
chercher et apparemment là on va le
chercher cela fait pas du bien au niger
et puis de l'autre côté c'est
sécher nazarbaïev
à chaque fois je mélange le kazakhstan
et 2 et les azéri bon bref
donc il n'y en a pas faut pas raconter
d'histoires faut les chercher et comme
vous dépendez d'un fournisseur
il a un petit moyen de pression sur nous
donc c'est pas vrai qu'on est
indépendant
mais je mets toutes ces questions je les
laisse de côté y compris le fait que le
seul nucléaire qu'on ait utilisé
cd nucléaire de centrales à eau
pressurisée
personnes
à léo c'est ça me saoule arrête jehanno
cerveau bon enfin donc le système en
question notre français on l'a adapté au
nom des paquets de licences qui ont été
déposées c'est le système d'une firme
américaine s'appelle westinghouse à
l'horizon mais les rues de charme mais
en gros c'est hyper simple qui prend une
tu prends une boîte tu mets des crayons
d'uranium tous fous de la flotte ça la
chauffe tu l'as fait tourner dans un
circuit qui doit surtout pas s'ouvrir et
puis tu as un autre circuit qui suit cas
côte était posée dessus et hop la
chaleur ce transfert
et comme elle ce transfert dans le
circuit ça passe dans ma charge sa fille
de la vapeur et hop c'est parti la
vapeur est transformée en énergie donc
le gros truc que tu vois c'est rien
les trucs aux voix de l'eau à la fronde
la fumée blanche
c'est juste la flotte qui circulent là
dedans pour se refroidir
alors bon c'est un système
alors ils craquent partout non faut pas
le dire mais
comme entre temps rien n'échappe au
capitalisme et tout échappe aux services
publics eh ben la sous traitance pour
nettoyer pour ceux ci pour cela cd la
sous traitance et la sous traitance qui
and magic
c'est que le sous-traitant trouve des
sous traitants qui eux-mêmes malinkés
sont comme d'autres sous-traitants
et à la fin et enlève un couvercle sur
une centrale nucléaire pourrait par une
machin aux couvertures par terre
s'est produit
comment c'est possible un truc pareil
c'est comme tu te dis je vais faire
démarrer l'avion dernièrement pas
flamion tombe sur le dire mais vous
pilotez vous faites quoi c'est quoi
votre métier alors là évidemment les
types sont sérieux et dit mais qu'est ce
que c'est cette histoire et ils
découvrent qu'ils avaient quarante neuf
sous traitants en chêne du premier cas
avait donné l'ordre au dernier pour lui
le foot du couvercle d'accord
donc c'est des risques cela ils sont
vite tiennent pas la technique qui
tiennent aux êtres humains et aux
conditions dans lesquelles les actions
humaines se réalisent alors la question
déjà on commence par régler un le côté
indépendant en sûr et certain ça produit
tout le temps j'ajoute que aujourd'hui
ça porte un nom j'ai oublié comment
comme on dit mais enfin tu vois le temps
pendant lequel ça produit et où c'est en
pleine efficacité compte tenu des arrêts
qui se produisent aujourd'hui dans le
nucléaire
donc ce niveau de d'intermittence genre
comme ça s'arrête parce que faut réparer
parce que si parce que là la preuve
d'être chaude n'y en a pas assez ou je
sais pas quoi
le cet intermittent cela maintenant
celle de de l'éolien
en mer est meilleure que celle du
nucléaire pourquoi parce que comme dit
éolien en mer et éolien offshore cela
peut aussi être sur des piques et c'est
pas grave ce qui compte c'est que c'est
à vingt bornes de la côte pourquoi 20
mordent parce que là le vent est plus
régulier
- 2 - d'arrêt donc non plus plus outils
donc là aussi alors on met ça de côté et
on se concentre sur comme on fait ben
moi je suis je suis qu'un pauvre
intellectuelle de littérature tu vois
littérature finaux donc faut pas trop
interrogé sur l'échéance parce que j'y
connais rien enfin comme je suis en bas
un peu toi par exemple moi j'ai acheté
une machine à laver
la vaisselle
les 23 ans voulait pas faire la
vaisselle
alors ma femme faisait la vaisselle
j'étais mariée et ça me donner mauvaise
conscience en plus jean mon gamin était
ma gamine était petit nous avons
vraiment mauvaise conscience résultat
qu'est ce que j'ai fait chez recherche
d'une machine à laver laver sa chenille
pas comment tous mes copains se moquer
de moi à l'époque parce qu'il trouvait
sympa de faire la vaisselle pas moi moi
ça me saoulait de faire la vaisselle
d'accord donc acheté une machine
c'est pour dire que quand je me pose un
problème je regarde c'est une solution
donc puisque ici votre machin nucléaire
marche pas qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
ben justement où il ya d'énergie en
abondance on te dit le solaire
géothermie atteint commence par le
solaire le solaire à wii u pour que ça
marche il faut des matériaux qui que
quoi
virgules ah oui puis fauqué du soleil ok
il ya une réponse on peut travailler à
la luminescence je les ai vues de mes
propres yeux edf avait une chaîne qui
monte des panneaux qui fonctionnait à la
luminescence et edf a fermé la chaîne
donc faut pas dire on peut penser pas si
on sait le faire si je te prends la tour
montparnasse sur la cour de ces panneaux
mais minés sens eh ben je donne de
l'électricité à tout l'arrondissement
tue pas mal non si tu fais pareil avec
la tour qui a là bas à marseille où la
même chose donc des panneaux qui
fonctionne à la luminescence faisons du
soleil sans arrêt c'est un des exemples
mais même ça allait ok allez on laisse
tomber c'est trop compliqué il ya un
endroit où il ya une énergie
sans cesse renouvelé c'est la mère et la
flotte
pour la raison que l'eau le cycle de
l'eau 1 eh ben c'est l'évaporation la
pluie la rivière la rivière la mer la
mer l'évaporation la pluie ça tourne
comme ça depuis des millénaires et ça
s'arrêtera jamais aussi longtemps qu'il
y aura de la flotte du soleil pour qu'il
y ait de l'évaporation et qui aura des
pluies et des rivières
donc tu plais en met partout des
hydroliennes ça c'est le mot savant
avant on disait moulin bas maintenant
d'hydroliennes alors comptabilisés le
rôle yens partout est ce qu'on sait
faire des hydro les prix on s'est perdus
hydroliennes qui veulent en voir une va
à bordeaux il y en a deux il y en a une
c'est la française ils sont en train de
faire des tests et puis thomas une
deuxième passe à pourquoi ils sont juste
là des néo-zélandais je crois qu'en et
c'est une autre à côté donc on en met
partout et avec ça on a une puissance
installée
pour voir si c'était comment ça pouvait
fonctionner cette affaire je suis allé à
guadalupe et j'ai vu un gars qui est
clair alors on en fait c'est son truc
c'est pas tout à fait au point parce
qu'il y avait une centrale tu es la
centrale personnes en rien la centrale
et les grosses comme la table
c'est juste un moteur au delà il a pas
beaucoup d'argent donc qu'il a acheté un
petit moteur avec ça il fait 2 en poule
mais s'il mettait une machine un peu
plus importantes on a regardé avec lui
il clairet ils feraient de l'électricité
pour tout le secteur y compris pour son
resto à lui
pour faire les acras et tout ça c'est ça
consomme pas ce que ça ça bouge bref
donc c'est pas vrai qu'il faut commencer
tout ça tire à une tête de trois
kilomètres de long sur le thème à bach
il va falloir que faire de la sobriété
même s'il va falloir je terminerai par
ça mais donc je suis sur le saas et la
puissance des rivières le gars qu'est ce
qu'il a une rivière qui passe chez lui
et puis après bahia le mouvement de la
mère et la mère tant qu'il ya la lune la
mer bouge et ça ça contient 66 fois
l'énergie dont on a besoin à terme pour
les côtes françaises
quant à 1000 kilomètres d'eau coûte faut
quand même manip vraiment pas malin pour
pas être foutu dans sa halle et des
centrales en mer qu'il nous produisent
la quantité que produisent aujourd'hui
nos voeux centrales nucléaires alors
j'ai même été demandé combien il en
fallait pour faire l'équivalent d'une
centrale il te faut 45 une centrale ou
d'un réacteur fois que c'est avec toi il
te faut 45 que machin offshore
alors de la dernière génération c'est à
dire c'est avec des pales des toiles à
la pale de l'hélice effet 120 mètres
s'affaire une circonférence de 140 m
aujourd'hui ses 40 mais celle qu'on
recycle pas d'ailleurs de quoi la pale
de 120 m mais surtout recommandé oui les
pessimistes ont maintenant des gros trou
dans la terre existe des pales de dons
ouais mais ça va ça va le régler ça
parce que je vois pourquoi tu vas avoir
des pales en carbone dont ben non c'est
pas bien mais on va sûrement trouver
comment on s'y prend on peut tirer de ça
du câble nano carbonique des choses
comme ça faut que j'arrête parce
qu'après mon père tué parce qu'ils sont
contre les nanos truc
non mais parce qu'il y en a qui m'a
expliqué un jour qui voulait installer
un ascenseur entre la lune et la terre
l'accusé voulait mettre à son service
qu'à moi on fait toutes sortes de
propositions
au graphène un mec qui m'a dit ça à m
et il paraît que ça tiendrait c'est
pourquoi 50 fois plus résistante assez
bon disons qu'on peut faire des choses
plus raisonnable avant d'installer un
ascenseur entre la terre et la lune mais
si vous voulez voilà comment moi je
fonctionne j'ai confiance dans la
science et la technique et en même temps
je suis pas halluciné par la science et
la technique dire je me dis bon
pouvoir toujours vérifier ce qu'ils
avaient vers cible et si tout tourne mal
qu'est ce que ça donne alors après sur
la sobriété il ya un très bon bouquin
qui vient juste de paraître qui est de
martine billard
qui est l'ancien député écolo de paris
et qui est la cofondatrice avec moi deux
du parti de gauche à l'époque et elle a
fait un très joli bouquin sur la
sobriété que je dois lire je n'ai pas
encore lu re et je la connaisse une
fille sérieuse donc elle a bossé donc là
je vous donne raison on pourra pas dire
aux gens écoutaient la fête continue
comme avant tout éclairé la nuit vas-y
j'essaye de caser dans un de mes
discours de campagne je suis pas arrivé
encore cédé des dossiers que je sorte un
autre a déjà la flottille du mal j'ai
sorti je vais faire rebondir l'espace
rappelez vous les mecs disséminés ici de
quoi il parle ce tome mais se passerait
ben oui c'est un sujet et de défense
nationales mais là ces deux sujets c'est
la lumière et le bruit
la plus grosse dépense de santé
liés à des dégâts collatéraux c'est le
bruit s'est même pas l'air pourri qu'on
respire
alors j'ai ramassé des chaussures les
bruits et pourquoi le bruit détruit quoi
et puis la lumière et un quart de
l'humanité qui voit jamais la nuit si
j'ose dire mais c'est tout blanc éclairé
et vous vous êtes vous habitez par là
bas vers une forêt donc vous avez une
expérience que peu de gens est encore
nouveau de quoi ses traits luminescents
mais la nuit la vraie la nuit de chez
nuit bah maintenant peu de gens savent
ce que ça veut dire
les gens ils savent pas que la nuit et
les peaux noires elle est souvent bleu
parce qu'à la lune
la nuit quand elle est froide à elle
décide des choses elle les caches peur
et ainsi de suite la nuit c'était
milliers de sensations visuelles et
physiques dont sont privés déjà un peu
comme tu dis est dangereuse que jamais
vu la mer ou corée jamais vu une rivière
aux corréziens une vache toi dans mon
coin là bas comme j'étais conseiller
général les mots me dessiner des
vachettes et violette est bien conçu
ouais tu vois si le chocolat est ce le
match il avait jamais vu c'était celle
qu'ils avaient sur l'emballage
bon alors c'est pour dire qu' il ya des
sujets comme ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive
à
sortir pour faire penser et là nous on
était sur
la sobriété
de la consommation énergétique les
premières fois qu'on y réfléchisse l'on
se surprend soi-même à découvrir qu on
s'est tellement habitué à ce qui est de
la lumière dans la nuit que tu arrives
pas imaginer qu'il y en ait porte et
surtout en ville
alors pourtant pas si compliqué que ça
tu pourrais mettre des capteurs qui
passe de sous ça allume du temps à tout
ça étant et une fois c'est pas un bon
exemple que je prends pour mon cas
je me balade la nuit à la havane
1,26 à cuba jeu
léché de diable et il n'y a pas de
lumière la nuit à laval parce qu'alors
ils sont pris à la gorge comme ça tu
peux vraiment installer les américains
interdisent tout quand leur bangkok ce
soir
et a ou deux soirs ça vous a tellement
plus
qu'on est sortis dans la nuit pour voir
quel effet ça faisait
je n'aurais pas fait au mexique la
remise des coupes à mon psy mais
qui revient pas vivant quoi mais les
crocodiles sont
les crocodiles mesure mans mais à la
havane
les gens ils te parle dans la nuit sont
assis sur des bancs discutent entre eux
tu as tout lui eurent belles dents
noires enfin dans le noir dans la nuit
quoi est ce jour là on s'est dit ça on
s'est dit mais
finalement pourquoi on veut que de la
lumière juste parce qu'on a peur
on a peur pas peur du noir comme des
gosses pas peur de se faire attaquer on
a peur d'eux parce que comme on vit dans
un monde pourri avec des relations prix
de violence eh ben on l'a intégré
jusqu'au point de préférer tout éclairé
toute la nuit
tellement nuls quoi alors donc c'est là
c'est vous qui avez raison et aime la
lumière mais les gens ils seront jamais
leur annonce que je vais éteindre les
lumières dans la rue alors il faudrait
qu'elle s'allume et qu'elle était on
peut le faire et puis la pub qui peut
venir pourquoi la nuit qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'elle tu as besoin de regarder un
panneau publicitaire et nous les
français comme on se croit malin on se
rend pas compte d'eux on en est dans les
grandes villes du monde nous ça va c'est
à pied que c'est quasiment insupportable
mais tu vas dans des grandes villes au
d'amérique latine certaines ou d'asie
s'est éclairé mon pire qu'en plein jour
parce que c est l immeuble entier avec
des façades des fils des pubs
donc moi je me suis pas perdu on va voir
si vous perdez pas dans vos questions
est-ce que je suis quelqu'un qui a l'air
d'avoir une liste de questions
oui
c'est beaucoup de travail à vous parler
vous parlez de sobriété je vous parle de
sevrage énergétique
je vous parle de nucléaire vous me
parlez d'hydroliennes moi je vais vous
parler de deux sociétés de transformons
on a toujours transformé
on a fait des bâtons des bâtons au point
des arts continue et
si on donne une électricité ou une
source d'énergie à bon marché
est-ce qu'on va pas continuer la petite
musique de hama l'énergie coûte pas cher
on va transformer encore moins cher et
on continue et on continue et on
continue quel comment on fait pour faire
passer aux gens ça me dépasse parce que
ce que vous racontez là
je comprends ce nom vous parle et je
vois bien le lien qu'il ya entre
l'énergie abondante et le délire
productiviste je le vois bien
moi je sais que j'ai des choses à un jeu
nous avons des tâches à accomplir des
tâches pour réduire ses consommations
pour faire de la sobriété pour se mettre
dans l'obligation de changer
l'approvisionnement qui s'étaient armés
qu'est ce que ce sera
les sociétés dont on parle
au moment où est-ce qu'elles vont buter
sur le mur de la limite non mais je pose
la question d'autant plus sévèrement que
démographiquement
l'explosion des êtres humains
mécaniquement augmenter la quantité
d'énergie quel que soit le système
économique inversement ouais mais je ne
t'aurais pas eu deux milliards
d'individus si auparavant il n'y avait
pas eu les transformations permettant la
production dont le premier milliard
c'est 1820 le deuxième milliards c'est
1950 et en 51 la catastrophe commence
avec moi
et on est passé de 1 milliard à 2
milliards et demi ensuite on est passé à
7 milliards et on pense qu'on va aller
jusqu'à 10 ou 11 milliards puis le nom
va commencer à reculer
le recul on observe déjà à certains
endroits notamment dans les sociétés
européennes qui sont des sociétés
vieillissantes étaient des gens ils sont
beaucoup moins que tes conneries à
zemmour le grand place m'ont poussé à
bout dieu nous allons être remplacé ses
crêpes est remplacé vous avez intérêt à
trouver de l'aide parce que si vous
restez que vous êtes là bientôt il y
aura personne pour faire le boulot donc
tout ça est assez ridicule mais bon
d'accord donc le nombre on pense qu'il
va réduire à partir sur le nombre réduit
c'est parce qu'ils vivent parce qu'on
est plus vieux et donc plus dépendants
d'un tas de trucs donc de plus en plus
avec des besoins d'assistance à la
personne alors dans les sociétés initial
l'assistance à la personne c'est
d'autres personnes dans les sociétés
dans lesquelles nous vivons et dont
mousseron issue au moment où cette
question se posera les rapports humains
sont complètement explosé toutes les
structures traditionnelles d'entr'aide
n'existeront plus
et donc il faudra soit que la société se
réorganise se reconstitue soit faudra
augmenter cette aide le pardon c'est un
peu de science fiction à ce contrat
compte à tous les deux mais comme
justement j'en ai lu des trucs de
science fiction sur ce thème
le temps de
me représenter ce que ça pouvait être
quand je vois passer des statistiques
par exemple les statistiques sur la
baisse de la population en europe ça
intéresse pratiquement personne hein
mais c'est fondamental parce que toute
la vie des êtres humains dépendent leur
nombre là j'ai pas le temps mais même
mais même le fait d'être une espèce qui
est d'abord une espèce en apprentissage
c'est une caractéristique notre espèce
même nos enfants ont une de leurs
caractéristiques principales c'est pas
seulement marché de se mettre debout au
bout d'un moment 1 c'est que ils
apprennent et ils apprennent entre eux
dacca voir à quelle vitesse une bêtise
se propage parmi des mondes par
mimétisme
par mitsou oui mais pas seulement tu
vois regarde de gosse en un qui explique
à l'autre cia clémente qui sont comme ça
allait mais l'espèce humaine
alors statistiquement je me suis
intéressé à ça
mon petit jeu intellectuel s'étaient
tous rapprochés au nombre donc espèce
humaine qui apprend beau attaquer
rapport avec le nombre et je tombe sur
des articles jean-pierre gens qui font
ces formidables ans le nombre de gens
qui réfléchissent ce qu'ils font
intéresse personne c'est superbe et il
ya un gars comme ça qu'ils s'amusaient à
faire des pointages
pour dire ben voilà plus il ya de monde
et plus tu as une chance que le bon
geste soit reproduit
et
plus de type fille qui essaye de
reproduire le bon geste [__] de chance
qu'il y en a un qui fait n'importe quoi
mais c'est génial
donc l'accident génial et être capable
de faire la même chose que l'autre c'est
les deux conditions qui fait qu'on
trouve tout le temps des trucs à faire
qu'ils sont mieux qu'avant alors
les sociétés dont dont on parle quand le
nom va commencer à réduire
ça va être autre chose je sais pas mais
imaginez que vous et moi on se rencontre
moins 5000 avant notre ère et vous
n'auriez interrogé pour je sais pas quoi
moi comme ça pour votre curiosité pour
avoir quelque chose à raconter le soir à
la tribu vous voir lady vous imaginer un
truc où on appuie sur un bouton et ça
cuit tout seul
non moi je leur ai dit pas c'est que lui
tout seul qua non vos rides et un truc
bien tu vois bien préparer tout ça est
alors juste on met à chauffer tout cas
chauffer c'est génial bon bah on aurait
rigolé tous les deux jeux pourquoi
aurait bu un coup de cervoise monsieur
pascal abois ce moment là vous savez qui
a vanté le pin à
l'auditoire les romains
les grecs
les géorgiens
finale en géorgie très bon mais tu
parles et c'est là comme un trou et les
premières leur dois quelque chose ici
non plus de phylloxéra
c'est possible c'est possible mais en
tout cas les premières jarque ont tendu
un nom les romains c'est nul ils foutent
et de l'eau salée dans notre métier du
miel des cochonneries tout sort c'est
plus du vin tu vois c'est non il n'était
pas fort du tout en plus ça pue et rome
il paraît que ça pue et le tue c'est le
machin pour faire la nourriture et du
poisson
qui se décompose en la flotte alors
précisée mais beaucoup ça il paraît que
la mine pu être sport enfin c'est pas
notre sujet la romantique moi c'est pour
dire faut accepter de se dire qu'on sait
pas tout et qu'il ya des moments dans
l'histoire de l'humanité où il ya des
sceaux qui sont d'une manière ou d'une
autre juste vous voyez je dis même pas
en avant ou en arrière jeudi d'une
manière ou d'une autre donc on a
toujours là toujours continuer notre
croissance exponentielle en terme de
démographie et de consommation
énergétique
et à chaque fois on a eu un saut
technologique
on est passés charbon bell puis on est
monté voilà
si on n'a pas cet éclair de lucidité
avec le caillou productif cette beauté
du de la productivité du chaos
si on n'a pas ce ce saut technologique
oc ou la même si on trouve
comment vous allez gérer le
lapin la panique social de la violence
que ça va ça va entraîner trois les gens
vous demander des comptes
à ceux qui ont géré depuis 40 50
dernières années si c'est pas mal agi en
état de le faire je ne dis pas par an
comment vous vous allez pouvoir gérer en
fait une colère grandissante je ne
mangerai pas faire ça parce que parce
que c'est pas dans l'est
les choses qui peuvent se produire
négatives qui sont juste devant nous
c'est plutôt un effondrement de la
société qu'une discussion sur les
performances des moyens qui sont mis en
oeuvre quand je dis effondrement c'est
con tu te tapes de 3 crij vallée de la
hoya la route descend les canalisations
aussi tu reviens on peine en mai tournoi
aucun jours après sa commande à la fois
on répare plus chacun se débrouille la
société se se
dispersent il faut pas croire que on
sait pas on en a jamais vu des cas comme
ça on en a vu un il ya des zones de la
carte de
de l'afrique qui sont considérés comme
les hongrie ce dire oh tu sais plus très
bien à quoi correspond ce qui s'y passe
c'est à dire que les anciennes
structures tribales ont disparu au
profit des structures de la société
urbaine contemporaine qui elle-même se
sont effondrés pour des causes de guerre
civile et donc ressurgissent
mécaniquement tu ccc l'auto organisation
humaine des groupes humains qui donc je
ne crois pas que je serai confronté mois
à autre chose qu'à l'addition
d'événements disloquant la société
pour la période qui me concerne ce que
la chine est une comme le candidat à une
élection présidentielle mais comme
philosophe comme anthropologue
amateurs jeu un professionnel de la
chose
je pense que c'est ça les scénarios
négatifs les plus les plus probables
soient qu'il résulte de catastrophe
naturelle soit qu'ils résultent de
catastrophe industrielle qui détruisent
la société alors après on connaît des
règles mais varié tueur quelle que soit
la forme de la société quelques le soir
on sait que les êtres humains en période
de détresse se serre les coudes on
scie pourquoi pourquoi je le sais
parce qu'on a bien eu des études de fait
après les vous savez les événements en
louisiane katrina c'est tout katrina
ouais alors les à merlaut l'entr'aide
c'est pas leur truc donc ils ont ramassé
tout ce qu'ils trouvaient l'emmener
ailleurs
et puis ils ont commencé à spéculer sur
tout ce qui était cassée détruit pour
faire des sous avec mais ce qui était
intéressant c'était les études et on
trouve ça dans le bouquin de
est-ce que c'est hariri ou celui qu'ils
appellent ou sapiens ou bien ce que
c'est le bouquin de scott qui s'appelle
au mot et que domestiques us
et raconte que l'état à dire on va
envoyer l'armée pour pâques et de
pillages de viols et de alors d'accord
il y avait zéro problème il est des
premières n'a eu quand l'armée est
arrivée parce que les jeunes types qu'on
avait amené l'était pas du tout préparés
à ce genre de situation donc au premier
revers ça a été la débandade si j'ose
dire
donc je pense que ce qu'on peut jouer
je crois que c'est ces services
finalement la nouvelle loi de la jungle
le bouquin la nouvelle loi de gens que
ce service qui dit si vous y allez vous
entrez dans une crise comme ça et vous
mauvaise habitude de la société
néolibérale la crise sera pire pour vous
pour les autres mais si vous y entrez
avec les méthodes qui sont celles et une
culture de l'entr'aide vous en sortir
mieux et vous en sortirez
donc moi je suis pour
développer
la culture de l'entr'aide la société de
l'entr'aide donc tout ce qui va avec les
services publics le partage des
richesses bref ce que vous connaissez de
deux mois et de la politique ont comme
et communautés et surtout qu'on connait
par votre communauté on n'a jamais vu
des gens
se donner la main comme ça même avec des
gens qui n'aiment pas mais essaye au
départ ils se donnent la main
s'échangent des bouquins
et francs
alors
la société de l'entr'aide il m'est venu
une idée
on c'est une idée hein je dis pas
qu'elle est géniale mais
je n'imaginais que la structure de base
de l'entr'aide si je décide de veut
nous donner un coup de main
je connais à peine m'en fous mais je
vous trouve sympa je n'ai rien attendre
en retour
mais je vais plus loin je me suis dit
comment je peux organiser un truc pareil
et j'ai inventé un truc qui s'appelle
l'adoption sociale donc je vous adoptez
ces du manteau ring c'est avoir un
mentor
n'ont même pas un qui est un pote quoi
si ça va mal pour vous ben je vous donne
un coup de main et puis mettons que
c'est la cata pour vous eh ben
la loi dit que j'ai la même relation
avec vous que si vous étiez mon fils ou
si j'étais votre père dont j'ai des
devoirs vous savez que les ascendants
des devoirs sur les descendants et les
descendants sur les ascendants donc j'ai
inventé ce truc là et j'ai fait un texte
une proposition doit avec des copains
l'ont soumis
et je dois la dépose et là dans les
jours qui viennent avant que la session
soit terminé et ça s'appelle l'adoption
social alors
comme il faut toujours mettre quelque
chose dans l'emballage
c'est dire à ceux qui sont adoptés
socialement ils ont les règles
d'héritage
des liens directs de famille
en fait on veut le faire gérante
mais c'est un peu un prétexte parce que
l'idée qui est une petite structure de
base de gens qui décident qu'ils sont
solidaires recherché bon dans la rome
antique c'était très banal l'adoption
social on a pu s'associer à tout moment
là c'était très banal c'était plutôt
pour les patriciens jacques avait
quelque chose là où du pouvoir ensuite
j'ai regardé
d'autres petits modèles comme ça de gens
prenant charles xii gens et puis dans
marc d'un mât parentèle
méditerranéenne pieds-noirs
et y avait un truc qui se passe est
souvent c'est que
la plus jeune soeur rester à la maison
pour s'occuper des parm c'est horrible
ans mais c'est comme la grèce passée et
puis quand eux les pauvres pare brise
était plus là justement à ce rennais la
plus grande ou sait plus quoi en faire
parce que son époux était mort dont
commettez la pub et avec la plus jeune
et puis des fois c'était croisé entre
deux familles
et c'était les mêmes drames de gens qui
avaient juste une vie commune tu vois
qu'il cédait les mêmes drames qu'il ya
eu au début avant
avant le pacs dans les couples
homosexuels
je mange c'est comme ça que j'ai été
sensibilisé au problème des couples
homosexuels c'est l'horreur de comme
j'en avais un des deux qui mouraient
quoi l'autre subtilité dehors rien du
tout alors j'avais inventé un truc à
l'époque s'appelait le partenariat civil
le 1er mai qui dépose une loi six mois
sur ce qui est devenu après le pacs
et c'est pour dire c'était loin de mes
préoccupations de mon expérience de la
vie hein je n'étais pas dedans
et là c'est pareil sur l'adoption
sociale et intime qui m'écrit une fois
une gueule oui les [__] déjà le prend
tôt alors que massa semble de l'est sur
l'héritage on nous prend tous rendu
assez bon voir c'est quoi le mérite des
rites expliqué mois voire un peu ça va
quoi c'est le laps le facteur le plus
fondamental de reproduction des
inégalités donc c'est normal qu'un type
comme moi ça m'intéresse à ça en plus
moi je prétends confisquer tous de la 12
millions d'héritage savent à quoi ça
fait partie bord et blues millions
et à l'arrière les gens à la petite
maison personne n'a rien à craindre pour
sa petite maison la moyenne ses deux
enfants par famille donc la petite
maison faut qu'elle fasse 240000 pour
que tu commences à payer quelque chose
dessus parce que 240 me couper en deux
ça fait 100 à 1000 chacun et jusqu'à ça
mon ami tu paye rien
c'est pour dire que c'était la
discussion qui me saouler un peu mais
j'en ai profité pour dire ah bon
d'accord le gars en question il me dit
moi ma marraine qui m'aimait beaucoup
elle m'a donné tous et biars et l'état
m'a pris 60%
comme c'est la marraine qu'elle est
morte étouffée à tour chance que tu dis
que tu veux pas dire des choses
blessantes enfin c'est quoi le mérite
d'hériter de tamarin t'as fait quoi pour
faire ça
alors j mais en plus je me disais mais
ce qu'ils s'ennuient occupé de sa
marraine lui avant que avant qu'elle
meure parce que c'est dix fois c'est
vrai tu t'occupes de quelqu'un comme si
tu étais son fils ou comme s'il était
son père alors tu peux dire ouais c'est
cruel de rappeler à ce moment là voilà
comment est venue au moment de la faire
de l'héritage l'idée bien d'options
sociale et qu'on s'est mis à bosser sur
cette idée qu'a plus à pas mal de gens
donc la société de l'entr'aide ce
qu'elle aurait de
deux tu vois deux fondateurs séquelles
bien sûr là le reposerait sur les
services publics sur comme ça mais aussi
sur un comportement individuel de gens
alors j'ai fait ça une fois un
journaliste j'ai dit vous je vous adore
ils se marraient mais ça l'a fait
réfléchir
j'en profite pour passer une question
d'internet comment jean luc compte il
s'y prendre pour transformer des
consommateurs que les spectateurs
passifs
citoyens et partisan actif 9 5e peu
république ou politique de la vie
politique active de la vie politique
bon d'abord
peut-être que
si je retournais à mes 20 ans je
serai plein de décision définitive sur
le sujet
mais
j'ai bien vécu et je sais que ça sert à
rien dans des bras des gens avant tu es
là où la femme nouveau c'est une perte
de temps et ça se termine très mal
parce que tu vas être dans le normatif
et après tu va punir tu va surveiller
et très vite si quelqu'un a la folie de
se prendre pendant démiurge
ça va mal tourner moi je me prends pas
pour un des murs et
comme je pense à mes contemporains
je pense toujours avec bonhomie
tu vois c'est à dire que je me dis oh là
là on va trouver le moyen de s'arranger
léon trotsky disaient les masses travail
à l'économie et fontaine moins fatiguant
et bien je les comprends
je revis 20 ans je te réduit à ça passe
pas c'est comme ça la frc les faire là
non mais par contre ce qu'on peut faire
c'est activer les rouages qui fonctionne
dans la liberté
exemple moi je suis un militant
politique
si je gagne l'élection j'ai pas dis aux
gens venez soutenir le gouvernement tu
peux bien à quoi ça en quoi ça consiste
à soutenir le gouvernement tu te lèves
le matin étudie à la fenêtre je soutiens
gouvernement ça fait avancer quoi ça pas
du tout donc
si
on a ce pouvoir qui se met en place but
de l'union populaire jeu matin se
désengageront pas du tout d'accord avec
ça c'est normal c'est la vie
démocratique
des fois tu en as qui s'échauffent bon
ça aussi c'est normal moi j'ai envie ray
pas des flash-balls des grenades de
désencerclement et je ne laisserai
personne
et si quelqu'un s'amuse à tirer dans la
figure d'un autre il aura affaire à moi
enfin que chasser bondir mais qu'est ce
que je vais demander cher dire bec
citoyens actifs descendez
défendre et le système montrer vos
adversaires allez les voir
si les multinationales
une piège bas montrez leur que vous êtes
là bref mon idée c'est que le mouvement
politique par la présidence par les
instituts les institutions doit
continuer à pousser à l'action comme
c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ensuite il ya la façon de
traiter la société pas un exemple je
décide de faire
d'abord en la société et bienveillant
temps
on habille
tu vois mieux comme moi je prends le
métro j'ai aucun mérite un je ne le dis
pas pour la vie je prends le métro n'est
non je prends le métro c'est pourquoi
parce que hein j'arrive à l'heure de jeu
hors du bouchon ça me met dans un état
de nerfs que tu après idée donc je vais
dans le métro il n'est jamais de
bouchons des fois le métaux rares et non
des fois le mettrons est pas la leur
c'est tout 2 oui oui de noms de gens
tout ça ouais bon bah c'est la vie quoi
et les gens sont extrêmement courtois
c'est à dire que ça fait des années
comme je suis à paris que l'ue prend le
métro
personne ne m'a jamais embêté personnes
ceux qui m'aiment pas vous regarde comme
ça ceux qui m'aiment bien ils ont la
banane et et voilà le peuple français
les français enfin ceux qui sont dans le
métro
et qui sont pas tous français d'ailleurs
ils sont bienveillants donc c'est pas
être un naïf que de faire confiance à la
bienveillance des gens et quand on
appelle les gens à l'action collective
pour des choses d'intérimaires eh bien
ça marche ils aident tout d'un coup de
main pendant la coved on a organisé nous
des militants politiques des trucs qui
se faisait pas avant a amassé de la
nourriture et des bus du machin des
trucs hygiéniques pour les gens qui
étaient bloqués à la maison qui était de
boulot et tout ça eh ben vous avez pas
idée ont été emmenés devant le la grande
surface un homme était le chariot on
mais têtue et la pancarte et puis on me
donnait des tracts dire donné tu sais tu
avais des gens qui faisaient une course
de plus pour le mettre dans le chariot
donc et il le faisait pas tu vois genre
je vais sauver mon âme en faisant une
bonne action 1 une des genres bon ça
aide les hongrois alors où ça pourrait
m'arriver alors autant le faire
maintenant
je sais pas si c'est un calcul comme ça
ça c'est les libéraux il croit que tout
le monde calcule tout le temps mais non
quoi puisque les gens qui font des trucs
que c'est un peu pourquoi je suis parce
que c'est bien ou dix fois et ça
pourquoi justement presque de celui là
donc j'ai pas prendre des exemples
regarde le lieutenant colonel beltrame
le mec qui change sa place
face à un terroriste il remplace
un type de des champs plus alors il
hiller et remplace la personne qui va
mourir un gendarme l'incident là il est
lieutenant colonel oui mais les cathos
et il est franc maçon les deux à la fois
guide adorent gendarmes ça c'est vous
qui dites me le dit jean c'est un mois
peut-être qu'il était d'abord catho ou
peut-être qu'il était d'abord humaniste
peut-être que en voyant cette pauvre
victime il s'est dit moi je sais
pourquoi j'ai voulu et de gendarmes
parce que moi je veux aider le faible la
veuve et l'orphelin
hello guys longueur et il sait qu'il va
mourir il le fait quand même donc je dis
ça juste pour que par rapport aux
cyniques et aux gens qui pensent que
tout le monde est tendu tout le monde
est méchant et personne ne et des
personnes que c'est pas vrai alors pour
mia comme on va transformer etc ils vont
transformer tout seul parce qu'on va
leur proposer des grandes causes en quoi
ça consiste
dans une école d'ingénieurs sur des mots
à
les 25 26 ans quand ils finissent leurs
études
alors dit bon élève
phoma il laisse à la
caisse que moi quand et là je vous ai
besoin d'eux j'ai besoin de pales de 120
m s'il vous plaît faut qu'on puisse les
réciter parce que sinon après je me fais
engueuler je viens d'installer des pales
partout qu'on peut pas recycler aller au
boulot tu vas voir s'ils le font pas ils
le feront parce que quand on est
technicien ingénieur architecte garçons
aux filles les jouets ou leur boulot ils
aiment me faire bien aider et donner le
coup de main la trouvaille quand j'étais
conseiller général que pour le coup nous
voilà
le pognon ça oui ça à motiver des gens
un ca en motive encore pas mal mais
c'est plus ce que c'était il n'y a pas
la même
des années 90 c'était l'horreur là il se
voyait tous
pourquoi très de machin tout ça legrand
refrain c'était comme une entreprise il
faut que les écoles soit gérée comme une
entreprise il faut que je vois comme une
entreprise parce que l'entreprise tu
comprends c'est le paradis sur terre
donc il soin de la joie de bonheur et du
gaîté et de la gaieté le long des murs
évidemment que non mais c'était la mode
est maintenant sous les coups de la
prise de conscience
de l'état de la nature et du pillage et
du saccage qu'on exerce dedans il ya une
grosse conscience altruiste dans la
jeunesse et puis radical part
je cultive mon chic moi-même dans le
show écolo en fait quoi
j'ai mes plantes buzz sur le balcon
non c'est pas ça à quoi ces confiance
grande-allée votre de quoi il est plus
beau jeu même pas comment ces jeunes
non une année si j'ai eu j'ai une maison
de campagne j'ai acheté c'est pourquoi
jamais voulu par tous krainer oiseaux
nan mais sans déconner je veux surtout
avec des pavots comme ça avait en main
diard monsieur mélenchon il me faire une
petite production je comprenais même pas
de quoi on parle et tu vois alors
heureusement que l'on
bondir ça fait vieux nanarland une heure
une fois deux fois ça fait une heure 17
on n'a pas fait la politique
internationale ont les jets en a parlé
un peu woods s'est échouée de l'ukraine
où se voulait parler de craine parce que
pendant tout cette dislocation
géopolitique mondiale sous
des grands airs quand on se serre tous
les coudes pour faire bloc et qu'on fait
les sanctions fait tous bloc derrière ça
sent quand même la dislocation
géopolitique
la france au milieu de tout ça quel rôle
qu'est ce qu'on fait quels sont les
principes à sept principales menaces
géopolitiques
comment on va faire pour se sortir du
bordel j'ai pas fini ma gestion
là on voit on voit souvent que il ya eu
une libéralisation des fonctionnaires
quand je dis numérisation des
fonctionnaires c'est les cabinets de
conseil à tire larigot alors une
question dans la question c'est on se
retrouve avec des politiques qui ne font
plus confiance à leurs fonctionnaires
pour prendre des décisions des
stratégies quand la crise arrive où on
se retrouve face à des politiques qui ne
comprennent pas qu'on a énormément de
ressources chez vos fonctionnaires pour
trouver des solutions parce qu'ils
connaissent le terrain parce qu'ils
connaissent les stocks parce qu'ils sont
ils sont opérationnels donc pourquoi on
utilise des cabinets à gogo alors je me
fais l'avocat du diable c'est peut-être
parce que les fonctionnaires ben là rien
ou qui sont me regardez pas comme ça
le rookie sont déconnectés
non c'est idéologique les gens qui
utilisent les cabinets conseils pense
que le privé c'est mieux par exemple ils
ont organisé dans la loi maintenant le
pantouflage c'est à dire des gens
sortent du secteur public vont dans le
privé puis j'en ai privé peut venir dans
le public à chaque fois oui mais
pourquoi vous organisez denis bazar et
vous désorganiser la fonction publique
on dit même ça va faire deux le privé
c'est mieux quoi tu vois ils sont
inventifs imaginatif parce que bon il
c'est à dire que c'est pour ça le disent
et des idéologues eux mêmes ne
connaissent pas le fonctionnement du
privé il ya des bureaucraties privées
qui sont mille fois plus opaque
que n'importe quel bureaucratie d'état
vous n'êtes pas au quai d'orsay
dit pas trop de mal du quai d'orsay mais
j'aime bien cela alors vous avez bien
cela parce que c'est le deuxième réseau
diplomatique du monde derrière le
vatican parce que il servait ils
obéissent et ils ont une culture
professionnelle qui est très développé
et ils ont ils ont été trop obéissants
ils sont laissés faire
tous les ans de peur je sais pas
peut-être
c'est pas leur genre de manif pas de
pétition mondiale passe à ce départ et
d'année en année pré prix priorité les
moyens réduits et 30%
et puis on leur a demandé d'être absurde
que les diplomates qui faisait
représentant de commerce s'appelle la
diplomatie économique où il faut faire
ça pas besoin de battre les boîtes les
embauches et des types des hommes des
femmes pour faire le boulot quoi d'aller
vendre leur truc c'est leur job alors
que une ambassade donnant que nous temps
à autres pourquoi pas mais ça ne peut
pas être le boulot des ambassadeurs
alors je dis à la question numéro deux
après je la mets donc déjà avec moi tout
le monde dort plus un cabinet de conseil
parce que la ressource intellectuelle
elles existent dans l'état
et si tu l'as pas de chez pas on peut
demander au cnrs ou de demander à des
gens parce que l'état à des
fonctionnaires de très haut niveau ils
refusent pas le raid donc faut savoir
demander poliment des choses
compréhensibles mais quand on est à dire
je m'en vais voir le cabinet mckinsey
pour faire une enquête pour savoir quel
est le futur du métier d'enseignant ça
devient même pas l'esprit d'aller voir
des enseignants ou d'aller voir des
pédagogues ou d'aller voir des gens
qu'on a un qui sont dans les sciences
sociales et qui pourrait dire bah ouais
le métier a évolué à cause de ceci à
cause de ça bon et tu t'en vas donner
jusqu'à combien free ils sont monstrueux
à des types qui tue en fait tu recopies
rapport approche herriot nerfs parce que
sinon je vais avoir des emmerdements
judiciaire parce que maintenant on
judiciarise tous y compris des
conversations entendues alors bon donc
moi les cabinets conseils non non non
non la améliorer la ressource de l'état
oui
il ya bien des manières mais pas plus
malin qu'un autre et je vais faire que
dire des choses qu'on sait déjà après ea
vous me posez une question qui est très
sérieuse qui est la question de la place
de la france alors parce qu'ils y en a
pas sur les jus 67 millions et puis à ça
coûte trop cher
tu peux dire ce que tu veux ça coûte
trop cher il faut le faire ensemble
ouais voilà on va le faire ensemble
alors avec avec nos amis allemands avec
qui nous faisons un couple c'est bien
connu et s'adonne veut les délires
actuel qui évidemment se fracassent tous
les uns derrière les autres coups de
ridicule on va faire un avion du futur
avec les allemands sauf qu'ils ont
décidé d'acheter des f 35
rue baisse 35 5 1 européen avant oui
mais tu
et puis y est on sait qu'il ya pour que
voulait dire thompson et des rafales
d'acheter puis on va en faire un autre
d'avion commencé par acheter l'autre les
indiens h est
d'accord pourquoi pas vous vous croyez
que lancer un pays plus petits ghoul sur
un milliard deux cent mille 2 300
millions tu vois c'est pas les accords
avec les américains et voilà et voilà
mais moi je m'en fous les allemands font
ce qu'ils veulent mais ils trimballent
pas des bombes atomiques dans des f 35
parce que le f-35 qui doit homologuer
pourront transporter alors ça ça nous
regarde
et là tu as la discussion en ce moment
l'arrière leurs errements de l'allemagne
sont touche à dire quand même pas l'idée
est bien de moi j'ai pas d'accord les
allemands se réarme pas parce que parce
que ce serait un aveu pas et pourquoi je
regarde pas parce qu'il ya pas besoin on
s'en occupe nous les français donc pas
pourquoi les allemands auraient besoin
de se réarmer pour faire face à quel
ennemi s'il vous plaît on peut nous dire
de qui vous parlez bon alors inversement
pour nous les russes
les russes et les allemands
enfin en tout cas moi ma position et
elle est connue je suis non-alignés et
je suis j'ai toujours été parce que rien
n'est comprennent pas
semblant ils n'ont pas envie de
comprendre et le gala qui est premier
ministre de la finlande il ya non mais
attendez nous on est dans la lignée
c'est le pas dire neutre alors que t'es
pas neutre suivant les situations tu
penses que la raison clos par exemple
jusqu'à ce que les russes passent la
frontière d'une traîne pour moi les
provocateurs c'est si les américains
parce qu'il voulait englober l'ukraine
dans l'otan se disant qu'on leur dit ça
va mal tourner mais après c'est les
russes qu'on passait la frontière ce pas
les américains donc moi c'était critique
tandis que les autres exige pas d'accord
avec vous et parlera de passer la
frontière et je les dis sont entrés à
5h30 du matin c'était un communiqué
et je n'ai pas fait je pas parce que je
pourquoi le russe sait pas quoi mon fou
s'est fait parce que pour moi m'aime
pour ce que je représente pour ce que je
suis par rapport à mes amis copains je
suis le porte parole et à toute cette
opinion qui me soutient je suis leur
porte parole donc c'est mon devoir de
dire les choses alors non alignés
nous on peut français
peut le faire pourquoi je compris
défendre tout seul combien on vérifie qu
on peut se défendre tout seul
il ya des doutes sur certains aspects à
régler le problème mais moi ma lindsay
rose défend tout seul parce que ceux qui
peuvent pas des formes tout seul
eh ben ils né forment pas ou quand ils
se défendent c'est dans des conditions
catastrophiques
y a qu'à regarder ses preuves ukrainien
à qui tout le monde avaient tous promis
et qui pour finir son tout seul alors
bien sûr nous accueillons les réfugiés
et bien sûr nous aurions des gilet
pare-balles et
paroles verbales tout ça c'est bien
c'est mais ça comme ça n'a aucune
efficacité et même si on est appelés chi
c'est boutreux base jusqu'aux derniers
craignent un c'est ça l'histoire c'est
bien par proxy
donc là dans le cas de l'ukraine
laissent le le dossier du grain de côté
pour moi la réplique elle doit être
politique c'est à dire elle doit frapper
le pouvoir plus tenir au coeur c'est à
dire les oligarques et c'est pas sérieux
ce qu'on fait c'est une dépouille les
oligarques dans mon monde tu es certain
que le pouvoir poutinien ça a
déstabilisé c'est certain parce que ça
n'existe pas un pouvoir suspendu au
dessus des classes de la société ça
n'existe pas il est toujours
l'expression de groupe la société russe
majoritairement elle nationaliste très
nationaliste mais il a dit il ya des
manifs de protestation contre la guerre
alors vous parle peu la deuxième
centrale syndicale ils se font petit peu
taper dessus greymouth fonds bar qui on
est d'accord mais c'est un courage
extraordinaire non
les l'université de moscou
4500 profs et doctorants qui signe
contre la guerre c'est un courage inouï
tu trouverais pas ça en france un bon
ils le font
donc mais a donc je vais la question
d'ukraine deux côtés nous français
on doit se donner les moyens de se
défendre tout seul
on les a largement géré l'effort est pas
si grand que ça à faire se défendre tout
seul en tenant compte des conditions de
la guerre moderne donc discussions sur
la place de la dissuasion nucléaire dans
nos stratégies alors pourquoi parce que
si nos sous-marins sont détectables on a
l'air mal à avoir des sous marins
nucléaires que tout le monde était que
tu te coûte un fric fou et ça sert à
rien parce qu' à l'instant même où la
guerre commencerait tapis de sous marins
bon
alors on vous dit mais non mais non il y
en a encore pour 20 ans ouais d'accord
30 si vous voulez et alors on prépare
quoi d'ici là qu'est ce qu'on fait
nathan moi je suis pas d'accord
on dise votre prisme de lecture il ya
dix vingt trente ans pour changer la
doctrine de défense nationale
bat vraiment se dépêcher tu vois
moi je pense que
je veux le concept de dissuasion gelé
compris j'assume
mais en même temps je dit
j'assume parce que mais là au calme en
train de parler hein mais imagine la
situation on a un adversaire pourquoi ça
a dégénéré avec les ruches je sais pas
quoi type a balancé un truc sur les
polonais lesquels polonais répliqué
américains disent et l'autre à 5 de
l'otan tout le monde rame au plafond et
au milieu de tout ça c'est jean-luc non
m'attend au milieu de tout ça on s'en
prend une
série mais on a fait sortir tous les
sous marins nucléaires ils sont en train
d'attaquer ce qui retire
mettons mettons que dans cette ambiance
il se passe quelque chose qui tourne mal
normalement qu'est ce tu es censé faire
quand tu es chef de l'état tu réplique
tu réplique
tu as toutes les raisons de le faire tu
as pris un mauvais coup nos intérêts
vitaux soient en cause où on a appris en
carrément sur notre territoire et toi tu
es là talent doigt sur le bouton alors
c'est plus compliqué que ce que croient
les jambes ce que les médias vous êtes
trop nerveux chez mélenchon dit ah oui
merci je confonds la boîte à boutons
atomique avec la boîte à thé ça va mal
tourner mais bon bref
c'est pour dire que souvent les
remarques que je reçois elles sont pas
très intelligente mais qui va prendre
comme homme comme être humain la
décision que parce que tu m'as détruit
la moitié du pays je détruis le tiers du
diamant c'est à dire que moi tout seul
je décide de la mort de quatre cent
mille cinq cent mille six cent mille
personnes ce n'est pas rien ça qu'on en
parle comme ça on peut en parler mais
dans la vraie vie
c'est compliqué n'est ce pas alors mieux
voudrais avoir des stratégies qui te
laisse plus de marge de manoeuvre non
nous n'avons pas il y en a une qui est
possible à mon avis un mail à regarder
pourquoi poutine est il arrivé à faire
ce qu'il fait parce qu'elle sadis à sa
méthode de combat c'est la dissuasion la
stratégie du fou au fort le gars casse
tout il arrive et bomba tout ce qu'ils
voient la cité les hôpitaux n'est pas
sur tout et tu te dis brazy des comptes
vers l'asie qu'est ce que tu fais à rien
parce que tu as compris que ferait la
guerre totale et la guerre totale tu en
veux pas heureusement en attendant c'est
les ukrainiens qui morfle et personne
n'avait rien prévu
non rire personne personne qui ceux qui
sont payés à prévoir ceux qui sont payés
à prévoir et ce qu'on fait beaucoup de
bruit etc leur bouche
alors j'en prends il ya deux cas nous
français 1 et puis les américains les
américains avaient raison ils ont dit ya
un danger attention il va entrer bon ils
ont vu juste ça fait depuis 2007 soit il
annonce à temps mais peut-être mais là
il avait dit de rentrer parce qu'il y
avait des manoeuvres à tous à des
réseaux merde ça s'est passé c'est bien
ce qu'ils ont dit qu'il s'est passé
marcy justement qu'est ce qu'ils avaient
prévu dans ce cas là bas rien la preuve
c'est qu'on vit encore
deuxième cas les français alors les
français eux
au point que beaucoup ont été induits en
erreur par ce genre d'infos ils ont
suivi monsieur z inscrits qui leur
disait bon on n'a pas besoin de cette
dramatisation nous ne voyons pas de
danger moi j'ai dix ans et ne sont pas
des rues sont pas en danger virgule de
l'aveu de d'après mafieuses et l'inscrit
alors quelques journaux français que je
ne nommerai pas aux coupes et la phrase
pour que dirait mélenchon et trompe tout
le temps non il est pas trompé mélenchon
je dédie ce que l'hôte à 10 et le mardi
de la semaine où les rues sont entrés en
ukraine il ya eu une comme une réunion
de la commission de défense et on nous a
dit nous avons les moyens de voir ce qui
se passe et nous n'en tirons pas les
mêmes conclusions que les américains
tels quels et je dois dire aux mérites
du chef d'état major des armées
qui l'a dit clairement nous sommes
trompés mais il s'est trompé et ceux qui
l'ont cru sont trompés avec
mais peu importe en tout cas ils ont
rien fait il aurait pu dire non non
c'est pas cette fois ci qu'il va y avoir
un problème donc des gamins qu'est ce
qu'on fait est d'aller savent pas et ne
font rien et là là la question
géopolitique
elle se double d'une question de
stratégie militaire qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ce genre de situation donc moi je
suis pour transporter le système de la
dissuasion non pas nucléaire mais de la
dissuasion dans l'espace qui est une
contradiction pour moi puisque je suis
pour la démilitarisation de l'espace
mais je me dis de ceux de cette
situation compliquée je peux tirer un
avantage qui dira écoutez nous savons
tous que depuis l'espace nous pouvons
couper les communications
nous pouvons couper
faire du hacking un de masse et donc
c'est une stratégie de riposte qui peut
être efficace
fragile non mais d'accord mais quand
même plus intéressante que de dire c'est
tout rien qui termine pas rien bon après
on peut discuter moi je suis pas mais je
suis pas un stratège je suis capable
d'imaginer une situation qui a pris à
des militaires c'est leur métier c'est
eux qui vont te dire on fait comme si
parce que dans ce cas là c'est comme ça
et ainsi de suite bon ça c'est le
comment moi je me représente la suite
des événements donc un jeu ne participe
pas la nuance autant c'est incroyable
parce que les journalistes me voit et me
disent vous ne trouvez pas que au
contraire la situation a prouvé qu'il
fallait avoir des alliés débit servent à
quoi il a lié aux ukrainiens ça leur
sert à quoi et elle nous tout ça nous
sert à quoi que l'autre 10 comme dubaï
de ne laisseront pas un centimètre carré
long de le dire je ne lui reproche pas
de le dire enfin on va faire la guerre
nucléaire avec
donc on est en situation très compliquée
intellectuellement
de quelle va être de stratégies de
réponse moi la mienne la voilà nous
sommes non-alignés excluant cas on
décide qu'on fait en s'occupant de nous
et de se défendre nous mêmes s il faut
frapper d'avoir des moyens de frappes
qui permettent une certaine
progressivité de la riposte ou alors on
décide qu'on est neutre moi je peux pour
qu'on soit neutre alors bon ça c'est le
contexte est pourquoi il dit qu'il ya
intérêt à se dépêcher de le faire c'est
que comme vous l'avez parfaitement dit
l'ordre géopolitique du monde est en
train de se disloquer donc des crises va
y en avoir des pagailles il ya 14 triste
de frontières sur le continent européen
14 alors on va attendre à chaque fois
que ça explose 1 mais surtout que
l'exemple russe pourrait faire réfléchir
beaucoup de monde je vais pas en dire
davantage mais je veux dire s'il suffit
d'être violent qui passaient la
frontière tout seul est tout bête après
ils te font des sanctions bas ça va quoi
donc c'est très dangereux comme
précédent moi ce qui me paraît le plus
horrible de ce que feront les russes
c'est d'abord l'inouï violence des
méthodes
et l'incroyable précédent qu'ils ont
créés en agissant comme ça alors un
précédent d'irak où les américains sont
un petit peu essuyé avec lui le 30 mars
la responsabilité de faire en ce moment
des comparaisons de cette nature et
corps on va pas faire c'est pour par
exemple cette nature là je la ferai pas
vous avez droit vous en prie développer
là
y'a tout proches et amis il ya plus
proche mais c'est vrai la yougoslavie a
servi
une guerre qui n'est pas décidée par
l'eau et n'est déclenchée par l'otan
aboutissant à la création d'un pseudo
état le kosovo sur la base d'un
référendum local
alors étonnez vous après que poutine
passe en disant que nous on a fait
pareil cas crime et donc nous les
français là dedans
on peut pas être les porte sacoches des
autres on l'a été pour les yougos ta vie
c'est une erreur mais il faut dire
attendez mais kosovo crime et même motif
même peine c'est l'onu qui organise un
référendum pour savoir ce que veulent
les populations donc on est prêt à
discuter de ça de même c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'il faut une conférence
extraordinaire des frontières de l'ouest
ces organisations de sécurité de
coopération en europe via les russes
dedans il ya tout le monde voit ce que
nous on a quelque chose à dire aux
russes aussi on a quelque chose à
demander ils ont installé des missiles
5000 kilomètres on n'est pas d'accord
celui-ci sami km c'est pour nous donc on
a des choses à mettre sur la table je
suppose que eux aussi en ont ils
pourront nous dire bah nous ne sommes
pas d'accord pour que les batteries
antimissiles en pologne parce que vous
menacez 75% de nos installations ils
l'ont déjà dit et monsieur hollande
avait trouvé que non ce n'est pas mon
problème qu'ont laissé faire par bras
alors
je vais vous dire je t'échange liste je
suis pas journaliste mais là vous
cherchez à légitimer la position dite
modulation des cotisations
à oui mais bien sûr c'est toujours ça
qui font donc c'est pour ça que moi
j'évite temps les raisonnements les
commentaires en ce moment une période de
guerre ça sert à rien rien tu peux dire
ce que tu veux c'est de transformer le
lendemain matin en blanc ou en noir
mois ils ont décidé j'étais pro poutine
qui clame un truc incroyable quoi le
seul type opposants sur place mais oui
pas que pouvoir puisque quand poutine
est venu à versailles je suis seul à
avoir dit je pas d'accord avec ça c'est
pas même pas moi qui le dis c'est pas
moi qui l'ait reçue à brégançon monsieur
matheron c'est pas moi qui l'ait reçue à
l'hôtel de ville qui était lui demander
de voter pour la france pour les jeux
olympiques c'est madame hidalgo
c'est eux qu'on fait tout ça
monsieur chirac qui lui a remis la
légion d'honneur après tout c'est un
criminel de guerre vous avez entendu
dire que je suis là non bien sûr que non
trop tard ils se sont tous trompés ils
n'ont pas voulu voir en face le problème
qui était posée parce que il considère
que c'est de l'anti américanisme de
critiquer le déploiement de l'otan et
ensuite quand poutine fait
l'inacceptable tu trouve encore des gens
pour venir lui plus recruter des alliés
en repeignant en poutinien des gens qui
ont d'abord on jamais été pour les uns
et pour les autres compagnies de l'être
moi je connais pas de français de
dirigeants politiques français qui ait
envie d'être poutinien aujourd'hui ça
existe pas qu'ils sont d'accord pour que
poutine passe les frontières avec ses
chars et son matériel il casse tout
autour de lui sauf qu'on a quand même
laissé faire comme on voulait pas régler
un certain nombre de problèmes on l'a
laissé faire se débrouiller qui est
tchétchène il a tout cassé c'est une
fois après c'est la syrie en tout cas
ces deux fois après bon donc ça veut
dire que mettez-vous ce que dieu ville
paru jeudi de villepin est très
intelligent il dit écoutez si vous
réfléchissez un problème seulement
d'après ce qu'il ya dans votre tête à
vous ne pourrez me régler mais si vous
réfléchissez vous demandant ce qu'elle a
dans la tête de l'autre évidemment que
ça devient un peu plus compliqué mais
lui cet homme là il a réglé ses
problèmes comme ça par une violence
absolue dans deux trois quatre cas et
puis tout à l'heure vous disiez c'est le
plus fondamental et va falloir que je
revienne pour qu'on en parle mais
le changement de l'ordre géopolitique
mondiale pendant qu'ils sont tous la
bouille en cadence les formidables
on vote à l'onu
alors heureusement la résolution
condamnant la russie a été adopté il
faut regarder le détail
tu découvres qu'
il ya ce but et internationales c'est
uniquement là où il ya le d'eau potable
au robinet c'est ça
la moitié de l'humanité
n'a pas voté les sanctions alors
gouverneur sont pas représentatifs allez
c'est reparti pour un tour on pense à la
place des autres on décide à la place
des autres ne sait tout mieux que les
autres moi je dis que cette initiation
qui est dangereuse
si vous avez les pays qui représentent
la moitié de l'humanité qui sont pas
d'accord pour sanctionner un acte aussi
barbare qui a été le franchissement de
la frontière il ya un problème ça comme
mots qu'il faut régler ou plus
exactement on va pas le régler comme on
trouve notre place là-dedans qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec qui on parle alors on a
la réponse est écrit danse on est avec
les américains en toutes circonstances
le point d'accord voilà on est avec eux
en toute circonstance par exemple nous
acceptons le le concept de 2,2 de guerre
froide là-bas en bas dans
que les américains ont déployé avec
l'australie la nouvelle zélande
l'angleterre face mais voilà et bien moi
je dis non magique où tout ce que vous
voulez nous fait pas que vous nous on a
nos propres territoires là bas parce que
nous on est directement concernée ils
veulent pas de nous mais on est
directement concerné on a été faire les
malins avec eux des manoeuvres ne sais
pas quoi ou à louer avec moi donc cette
scop ça non on arrête mais par contre
les territoires français pas touche et
puis avec des gens qui a là où parle
voilà bah on discute on en parle vous
parlez de villepin qui qui va discuter
c'est quand même un ministre des
affaires étrangères qui a laissé son nom
dans l'histoire donc on parle comment
aux autres valère pas on va leur parler
comme on leur parle
ça c'est j'en fais pas les hauts faits
pas les monsieur je sais tout des
conseils à tout le monde tu vois comme
c'est plein d'arrogance aujourd'hui un
nom on y parle aux gens en voyant qu est
ce qu on pourrait avoir comme une cause
commune c'est pour ça que je dis non
alignés
indépendant
altermondialistes quelles sont les
causes communes alors les français ou
bien par où les notes caisse et dire
vous avez vu où vous casser la tête à
tous comme ton veut parce qu'on est une
bombe atomique
on a un porte-avions en avant bref on a
tous allégeance à ben c'est pas la peine
d'en rajouter temps à autre on leur
montre que ça marche bien pour que tout
le monde réfléchit sérieusement à nous
mais surtout on fait des propositions
d'actions communes ce que j'appelle des
actions communes ces actions
altermondialiste en quoi ça consiste par
exemple la mer est un enjeu du futur bon
et ben y'a pas de droits des grands fous
tu arrives tu penses que tu veux c'est à
toi bon donc nous les français on doit
être
à l'avant garde de dire attendez fait
pas comme ça nous mais pour qui les
droits des grands fonds parce que le
monde est le deuxième territoire
maritime du monde donc nous les grands
fonds c'est juste à la limite de chez
nous donc ça nous intéresse chacun vient
va faire ce qu'il veut et tout
dégueulasse et bon je parle un peu
vulgairement là mais c'est pour dire je
peux prendre mon truc là là la bolivie a
proposé qu' un tribunal international
pour l'écocide
elle va nous les français on est là
dedans mais si tu veux ça une fois deux
fois trois fois avec des ce qu'ils
veulent on pousse l'idée nos diplomates
au lieu de vendre des chemises et des
parfums ou je sais pas quoi ce qu'on
leur demande de vendre et bien en
réunion dans les ambassades et puis on
discute pas faire si on va faire là bon
voilà est-ce que pensez-vous 2 c'est
leur métier savent le faire ils savent
comment commence la conversation comme
on l'a fini à quel moment on peut
prendre des initiatives lancées à sale
je crois et on a la chance d'avoir
deuxième réseau du monde à faux le faux
le bétonner faut le renforcer on n'a
rien à faire avec la diplomatie
européenne en face une mauvaise blague
diplomatie de quoi ils vont embaucher
5000 type pour faire quoi alors les sous
à des sous il y en a alors nous pendant
ce temps nos ambassades ils tirent la
langue jusqu'à par terre je me rappelle
dans certains pays moi je vais toujours
voir les instituts français puis
formidable ces français là bonne
supportable softpower
supportable alors on disparaît et [__]
3,14 anglo saxons qui sont là qui vante
je sais pas quoi aux gens du coin et des
sourires un comble moi je suis
absolument content ce truc la diplomatie
européenne n'a pas de sens si je mens
jamais la moindre position commune
regardez là encore
regarder à quel point c'est nul c'est
que tu es jeune pas regarder ça en face
alors que tout cela oui alors nous
allons arrêter de d'acheter du gaz russe
en gros tu gaz américain
c'est tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé à faire
et le prix de gros de l'essence
pourquoi il n'ya pas un prix bloqués en
europe genre les européens nous achetons
à 1 euro
voilà où vous les plus chères on prend
pas à drew le litre tu vois adro lui si
on achète un nouveau lit tous veulent
sortir à combien non non j'ai compris
mais c'est pour dire pour qu'on arrive à
ce résultat là je sais pas où on en est
aujourd'hui mais quand est il faudrait
déduire sandales non c'est bien mais
c'est surtout le prix du baril de
pétrole
qui monte qui monte qui monte qui monte
donc la somme il se fait des poches
comme ce à quoi le le pétrole de schiste
il et il est rentable à 60 dollars le
baril aujourd'hui thé parce qu'à 200
tu t'imagines le fric qu'ils rentrent
ont fait de vrais d'interviews sur le
pétrole d'ailleurs
je veux rien dire mais je dis juste ça
quand vous avez des guerres suivez le
'pipeline'
je suivais le gazoduc et vous allez voir
comment tout le monde
le nôtre monde et c'est un monde
capitaliste dominé par les relations
capitaliste ils sont des relations de
compétition dans lequel les
états-nations nullement disparu et qui
sont tous plus ou moins
comment dire le conseil d'administration
d'un ensemble de d'entreprises qui sont
autant de moyens depuis sans vous
raymond harbaoui pipi qui peut relier
aussi un peu gag marque ça fait pas de
mal ça rappellera que les intérêts
matériels même le monde quoi comme mon
père sur internet entre guillemets nouna
ligne et ce n'est pas ni plus ni moins
être un soumis au final et ben oui
pourquoi ne pas faire ce lien pour se
faire comprendre plus facile parce que
moi je fais le pari que les gens même
ceux qui crient après moi réfléchissent
comme un vrai ce que je raconte ce qu'il
voit bien que je ne suis pas un homme
qui reproduit ces raisonnements qui
j'espère que ça se joue à quoi bon alors
bien sûr que ces insoumis à échelle
internationale
et c'est d'ailleurs en réfléchissant à
partir de l'idée d'insoumission que pour
ma part j'ai l'on construit tout un
vocabulaire
ça fait non alignés est une expression
que j'emploie depuis un certain temps
mais sa centralité pendant un temps on
disait un nouvel indépendantiste
français c'est encore plus compliqué à
comprendre que le souverainisme alors
bon puis
ccc surchargé
c'est ce qu'a pu juste le nouvel
indépendantisme une nouvelle manière
d'être indépendant mais qui ne soit pas
en même temps à un repli sur soi le
refus de parler aux autres ou une
neutralité qui est impossible à tenir et
évidemment que le concept de non
alignement et en plus il renvoie à un
moment d'histoire
du monde 1
et puis j'ai testé aussi parce que j'ai
quand même des amis un petit peu dans
tous les pays moi je travaille pas toute
seule
qu'elle était l'expression qui nous
convenait le mieux vous avez aux autres
voilà si je parle avec un mexicain
expliquons les insoumis internationale
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué pour
lui que dire parce qu'autant qui dit
schümann enchaîné savons n'y a pas
besoin de moi pour faire la bonne
politique par du mexique pour blaguer 1
mais je veux dire par là que on a besoin
d'avoir de vocabulaire commun des choses
sur lesquelles on s'accorde tous ça pour
avoir vocabulaire commun vous avez de la
chance vous avez grandi dans la ceinture
méditerranéenne
vous avez vécu dans un autre pays vous
avez des amis à l'international vous
avez peut-être vécu là du sud un petit
temps ou des choses comme ça est ce que
nos politiques nos hauts fonctionnaires
doivent avoir vécu à l'étranger
connaître les gens la culture et non pas
avec un prisme de lecture on se comprend
non mais là vous avez raison pouvait
appuyer un moment où ça fait mal quoi
parce que la plupart de tous ces
baratineurs qui passent leur temps à
désigner les autres comme des repliés
sur eux tune et à personne que jamais
sortis de chez eux ou comme par hasard
ils en sortent et pour rester entre eux
il ya une sorte de jet set
internationale et même des fois c'est un
peu des experts non mais tu vois bon non
non non je parle pas d'eux des expats
qui voit saint leu le prof le
l'ingénieur le nom mais je parle je dis
je parle moi de ce que je connais les
militants politiques les dirigeants de
partis ils sortent et qu'est-ce qu'ils
font alors ils vont à l'internationale
socialiste où il rencontre les autres
qu'ils ont haussier je me rappelle une
fois je suis allé un congrès de
l'internationale c'était à j'étais
socialiste je crois que c'était parfait
à l'époque ça valait le coup
et attends je crois que c'était rio dé
janeiro enfin bon bref on va là-bas et
puis à halle en ouvre là avec tout le
monde patati patata l'arrêt que des
textes qui valait même pas une
résolution de nos venu tellement c'était
mièvre tu vois pour qu'ils arrivent à se
mettre d'accord parce qu'évidemment ceux
qui sont au gouvernement veut qu'on
critique rien ceux qui sont convoqués
aux critiques taux mais pas trop parce
qu'un jour ou l'autre on sera au
gouvernement et en vaudra rien critiquer
ce parce que tout le monde suit enfin
c'est sale ambiance de genre de réunion
et puis pendant que l' union a lieu je
m'aperçois que quant au sort du lieu de
la réunion n'y a rien c'est à dire tu as
des autoroutes autour donc tu sors pas
je reviens dans la réunion elle soir
nous emmène à l'hôtel crillon l'hôtel
bel hôtel trop cher d'ailleurs ne pas
quitter même tous mis d'accord pour
protester
et qu'est ce qui se passe à l'hôtel t'as
pas de trottoir
tu comprends tu es une espèce deal au
milieu de l'autoroute et si tu veux
sortir tu appelles 1 takuma cher donc tu
vis avec personne tu vois rien togo ne
rien ta rencontre était vieux pote de la
dernière fois que la fois d'avant la
fois d'avant de la fois d'avant de la
réunion de gens qui se fréquente entre
eux
et vivent pas dans le
en tout cas à l'époque ça m'avait ça
m'avait choqué
par ce que il y avait tout un mouvement
vivent là quand on allait au brésil
c'était le parti des travailleurs de
lula qui était et aux deux vivent avec
le mouvement des sans terre avec
je me dis qu'est ce qu'on fout là qu'est
ce qu'on fout là au plus les trois
quarts parler en anglais et pas en
espagnol et en portugais
je trouve qu'il ya eu 1 dans les milieux
sont bien sentis non ça c'est un peu tu
vois ça s'est appauvrie sas est
desséchée ils se lisent pas entre eux
moi j'ai pris une décision il ya de cela
deux ans c'est que on traduisait des
textes des autres des textes ordinaire
pas les trucs sont des books and sales
et les éditeurs le font ils le font bien
bien mieux que nous mais des textes
internes et les miens on les traduit
aussi ou ceux de quelques copains et là
depuis
disons 10 ans il ya une très grande
interpénétration disent qu'ici on
appelle la gauche radicale
où on échange beaucoup nos textes il ya
une certaine homogénéisation
de nos revendications et de notre
manière de poser les problèmes par
exemple quasiment tous nous sommes
devenus
écosocialiste
dire maintenant c'est rare ceux qui font
un chapitre écologie un chapitre social
très nombreux sont ceux qui sans arrêt
interpénètrent les deux donc il ya eu un
progrès de la conscience collective mais
à un moment non théâtre chacun dans son
coin tout en ignorant tout le monde là
il espère tous que je gagne la
présidentielle
ils espèrent tous bas comme ça les
aiderait tous on va pas faire de
pronostics mais je me suis amusé à
prendre les les scores de la gauche tous
partis confondus
les scores de la droite tous partis
confondus
et on va dire les scores l'extrême
droite tout parti que
ça va être compliqué d'être président
jean-luc sion
ça dépend comment on regarde la vie
la société a l'air lente ou paumé et les
étiquettes ne veulent rien dire pour
elle les gens ils ont pointé des
problèmes
les gens chacun peut depuis son balcon
souvent
est une chose leur paraît prioritaire
une autre les gens cherchent
désespérément à comprendre ce qui leur
arrive
et on leur explique des foreurs dit bon
voilà c'est la faute des immigrés écrit
je crois pas qu'il le croit aujourd'hui
mais bon il ya des idées qui ont été
terriblement banalisée il ya des gens
qui sont responsables de sa de l'avoir
fait
à un moment donné on a davantage dé
diaboliser madame le pen et on m'a
diabolisé mois dix fois plus
qu'eux mêmes il l'avait fait autrefois
pour le père le pen
mais il faut pas avoir de l'amertume ou
d'aigreur il faut prendre la vie comme
tout comme un ensemble d'événements est
fondamentalement la société est paumé et
fondamentalement elle sent que pour
changer et pas aller à la catastrophe
il faudrait beaucoup changé de choses il
fondamentalement
on veut puis on veut pas tu vois on veut
mais bon mais pas moi d'abord
il y à de la résistance à ça et puis
dans la jeune génération il ya une
volonté mais terrible d'aller au bout du
truc au bout du changement donc moi je
suis optimiste bien sûr que c'est pas ça
vous avez un million de fois raison mais
ça a été quand simple souvent je demande
aux gens c'est quand l'époque où c'était
simple
jamais et jamais nous avec le recul de
l'histoire on trouve sa place à présent
de deux situations mais comme tu les
regardes de l'intérieur à l'époque
un chat y retrouver pas ses petits
aider on parle on travaille ensemble
on leur dit les choses qu'on n'accepte
pas qu'on leur dicte et non n'est pas
d'accord est ce que vous faites
on leur dit y'a pas besoin de les
insulter pour le faire et puis on peut
écouter ce qu'ils ont à nous dire et
puis on peut leur répondre
mais ce qui ne sert à rien c'est de les
menacer
et de les encercler mais se sert à rien
j'aimerais juste à se faire plaisir
peut-être dans des dans des réunions et
acheter des armes et en vendre mais
c'est tout un pays qui est là depuis
quelques millénaires août à 1 milliard
500 millions de gens qui produit
l'essentiel des objets matériels de
notre époque
faut peut-être réalisé là pour réaliser
ou ans n'est pas juste parler comme ça
il ya plus un ordinateur sur sur cette
planète si ils font pas le boulot
pour prendre que l'exemple de
l'ordinateur jeu pour reprendre des
dizaines d'objets comme ça à vous êtes
tous les cd faire trouviez ça bien les
chinois ibos et puis vous fier du
service 1 et bien voilà le résultat est
même plus foutu d'avoir les poireaux
dont j'ai besoin voilà le résultat les
faits même plus faire des masques en
tissu
sa fille qu 1h54 qu'on est ensemble il
faut le voir là il a
cette fois ci statue attendu mais je
vous demande de comprendre je suis venu
michel durand tenir comment on fait pour
tenir le calendrier
l'enthousiaste ouais bon je prends deux
trois questions et puis allez vas y
avait aussi deux répond brillamment
chaîne ma photo 6 1 alors il ya eu des
questions concernant le dernier article
de mediapart sur le fait que c'est ça
est surfacturé qui est pas maintenant
geffosses a
balayé d'un revers de la main couplé au
quai et attends je peux même me marrer
je crois que alors d'abord je suis pas
concerné perso
non non non moi mes comptes de campagne
sont valides et personnes dit qu'il
n'était pas honnête et puis si vraiment
il faut aller chercher sur les trucs
bizarres ya peut-être plus urgent que
moi non mais c'est pas seulement je
laisse ça de côté ce qui me fait marrer
c'est d'avoir lu les premiers les juges
il adore ça a pas d'amour il découpe les
inculpations tu vois il inculpe tes
cheveux puis après ta tête et après tes
bras etc et puis les pinceaux de
terrifiantes
jeune escroc aggravée alors que vous ne
se dit mon dieu double ration non
aggravée c'est parce que il est question
d'un service de l'état le fisc et puis
l'escroc il est qu'à minuit le gac a été
inculpé c'est le c'est un événement
mondial c'est le premier escrocs
bénévoles du monde s'est produite 720
rien passé a pris 0 même pas une belle
et les deux autres qui sont dans le
collimateur e et gagner moins de mille
balles par mois et l'association dont il
est question sur cinq cent mille euros
de chiffre d'affaires elle a fait 6000
euros
de bénéfices mais comme c'est une
association s'est distribué à personne
voilà de quoi on parle mais tu vois ça
fait bien tu as une occupation c'est
terrible alors les gens ils sont mal
parce que ça n'a fait aucun il ya eu
aucun rebond au camp tout le monde s'est
dit c'est de la connerie et c'est de la
connerie
question internet on va se creuser on va
prendre la première qui parce
que 90 de la revue chercher les c'est le
typique la stasi non chacun son boulot
c'est à vous de poser des questions moi
je fais les réponses
que pense-t-il de la caricature de sa
position par les médias sont en encore
paradis bon
mais franchement c'est vrai que c'est un
défi intellectuel quand tu dois passer
ton temps à répondre des trucs qui ne
concerne pas et que c'est comme si on me
dit souvent ça certains ont pensé parce
qu'en plus c'est des lâches ils te
disent pas qui c'est qu'a pensé que vous
étiez vous êtes suspects deux poutinisme
le réarmement de l'allemagne un petit
peu d 'hier ou un délit je suis contre
d'accord y'a pas besoin qu'est-ce qu'on
va prendre d'autres comme en prévente la
majorité on nage à paris ouais oui
disons qu'en bon soir et à quoi le font
des blagues
pouvez-vous détailler le processus de
convocation de la constituante s'il vous
plaît
alors là je parle sous le contrôle
extrêmement vigilant toute sorte de
copain
mon anglais tous compris ce que c'est à
quoi ça sert
donc on commence par lé
la convocation de ladite constituante
à mon avis faut le faire par référendum
soit au titre de l'article 11
organisation des pouvoirs publics ou 89
mais ça te jury s'en débrouille et une
fois que le peuple à voter pour dire oui
on convoque la constituante on élimine
constituante
c'est à dire qu'on élit des députés que
20 des députés les gens que pour faire
ça mais c'est des gens dont il serait
bien convenu avant qu'ils n'auront
jamais été lu nulle part dans une
assemblée avant sénat parlement européen
et cette assemblée se réunit plat ya
plusieurs possibilités
est ce que l part de la constitution
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui à l'arrêt
visait la réécrit est ce que il ya un
comité qui fait des propositions
à l'intérieur de cette assemblée et puis
ils travaillent ils écoutent qu'ils
reçoivent
et écrire une constitution puis elle est
soumise à nouveau à référendum on peut
penser qu'un processus comme ça
s'apprend total
la délibération elle même un moelleux le
référendum avant et moi le référendum
après il y en a pour eux un en or et
demi un geste qu'on a pu voir dans
d'autres pays question at il vu la vidéo
de frédéric lordon sur ce qui se passera
s'il était ivre on a parlé
maintenant je vais pas je n'ai pas vu
non il me dirait la terre entière contre
moi
la dette françaises très attaquées par
les finances internationales
qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre la finance
internationale
on se base souvent on se balance défend
ouais mais j'ai des bonnes odeurs ou
essayer
et pas tous les mêmes moyens que nous
nous sommes un pays où il ya cinq
banques systémiques
nous avons
de 1200 milliards de dette je recommande
à tout le monde de rester raisonnable
si on répudie d'autres bêtes et les
autres vont pas être contents l'effet
domino
je pensais pas raisonnable que la france
soit attaqué pas raisonnable parce que
le résultat pourrait être désastreux
pour tout le monde n'est même pas pour
nous un bon j'y suis une brêle
la dissuasion financière ça existe aussi
un mois j'avais dit à chypre à ce jeu me
l'avait dit ne baisse pas les yeux dis
leur que tu es prêt à payer mais t'as
pas les sous et tu t'en vas en pleurant
et tu vas voir s'ils n'ont pas de courir
derrière dans le couloir pour te dire
monsieur revenez ici on trouve un
arrangement parce que si tu fait
banqueroute y en a pour 45 milliards
pour les français 60 samia pour les
allemands ça s'appelle mécanisme
européen de stabilité
pour la société générale non pour le
mécanisme il est étatique tu sais de
garantie c'est la cata pour tout le
monde 1 donc moi je suis pour que je
pense que les gens se seront
raisonnables ils font pas trop de
bêtises
mais c'est je recommande à personne
s'attaquer à la france si c'est moi qui
m'en occupe
est ce que vous voulez parler d'un sujet
en particulier on se quitte là on a fait
le tour j'ai bien aimé que l'on n'est
plus un petit peu
partir dans des choses et d'autres
au départ de notre entretien je pense
qu'au fond notre art consiste à
peut-être encouragés le narcissisme de
vos interlocuteurs non non parce que
quand même vous m'a laissé parler non là
on essaie d'adapter on va entrer dans
les secrets de fabrication on essaie de
s'adapter en face selon sujet selon
selon ce qui a fait ressortir way
l'avantagent de jean luc mélenchon sait
que c'est on disait un truc ce matin sur
twitter qu'ils aient
à jean luc mélenchon qu'est-ce qu'il est
antipathique
oui c'est vrai [__]
c'est parce que nous on a la chance
je sais pas je n'ai pas essayé c'est
réussi quand même
alors je vous rassure sur un point ils
ont fait ça tous les leaders de la
gauche depuis tout le temps depuis tout
le temps moi je cite souvent jean jaurès
parce que je me suis intéressé de voir
comment ils ont décrit le malheureux on
les images des trucs horribles et puis
dans tous les pays c'est toujours les
mêmes étiquettes et même les mêmes
choses et surtout nous a toujours
bestialité s'il faut bien comprendre le
truc il faut qu'on apparaissent non pas
comme des êtres de raisons mais comme
des animaux ils dans leur vision les
animaux soit imprévisible
le
cible bondissant et dans tous les pays
c'est pareil alors moi ça m'a beaucoup
aidé pour résister parce que vous savez
c'est dur parce qu'on met le miroir tout
le temps te traiter d'une manière à la
fin tu finis par te dire mais qu'est ce
que j'ai fait tu te sens coupable on
fait souvent ça aux femmes leur diamètre
est tu vas tu vas te calme était
hystérique mais qu'est ce que c'est
alors au bout d'un moment les gens
disent elles se disent mais bon il faut
peut-être que je me calme et puis temps
finit plus de cotiser aux exigences de
l'adversaire moi j'ai résisté en vendant
compte qu'on était tout raté pareille et
c'est pas moi qui était le plus
maltraité
pablo iglesias ont espagne il a pris
cher en plus il avait une petite queue
de cheval alors lui ouah il ya eu des
commandos devant sa porte pendant huit
mois 9 mois dix mois qu'il insultait
évidemment quand il rentrait quand il
sortait ses gosses
la presse espagnole a publié des photos
de corps de sa femme était enceinte
comment ça s'appelle à les photographes
et
un papa rased non le truc non c'est pas
propre à redresser le aller les photos
de l'intérieur quoi graphie
l'échographie merci monsieur le baron
d'échographie ou publier l'échographie
de
de son épouse qui est une militante
politique elle aussi tu affrontes
comment il a résisté un truc pareil
c'est à dire c'est les autres qui l'ont
fait des procès lui c'est parce qu'il a
fait au juste il essaie de se défendre
allons mais il faut voir celui de la
colombie la moitié du temps l'objet de
se tailler de combi parce que c'est trop
chaud pour lui ont tué la baille tue au
moins personne essayé de me tuer ils ont
dit qu'ils allaient faire mais n'ont pas
fait et je crois qu'il ya une forme de
vindicte comme ça à particulière plus
d'une façon générale la politique est
devenue plus à l' échelle mondiale
c'est peut-être une idée je me fais
parce que je cite ce jour là c'était pas
très ragoûtant l'époque contre lui donc
le bleu aps le portrait qui est fait de
moi c'est ça
alors après comme j'ai l'air fermé où sa
ville je regarde les yeux les gens
fixement maintenant qu'ils savent tous
que c'est parce que j'entends bali
comprennent mieux la regarde comme ça
si vous étiez le président vous accorder
l'asile à julian assange est dense on
donne évidemment non seulement leur
accorde l'asile mais j'ai des corps tous
les deux parce que tous les deux ont
aidé la france en dénonçant
l'espionnage dont elle a fait l'objet
moi j'ai toujours été à 100 je suis allé
le voir pendant qu'il était dans
l'ambassade d'équateur
là bas en grande bretagne et j'ai
participé tout le long comme je pouvais
à l'action pour eux pour le défendre en
sachant les fois où il fallait se mettre
un peu en retrait pour pas donner
l'impression que c'était un sujet 100%
gauche radicale quoi comme ils disent
question nicolas quelles sanctions pour
les élus qui ne tiennent pas leurs
promesses
le référendum révocatoire
puisqu'on va le mettre dans la
constitution les gens moyennant
certaines clauses il signature etc pour
ont révoqué les élus je pense que c'est
ça la vraie parade le
le laverait la vraie pourriture de la
vie publique c'est ne rien faire ne pas
tenir parole c'est pas c'est pas
seulement on trouve toujours les brebis
galeuses
bon des gens qui ont un comportement
inacceptable
financier ou autre y ait dans tous les
groupes humains taça mais par rapport
aux élus la véritable question la chose
la plus choquante
se faire élire sur une ligne en applique
à une autre parce que ça ça ça
complètement défiguré la démocratie en
france a commencé en 2005 avec tout le
monde dit non et de résultat ou ebay
c'est oui alors là à partir de là ça a
été la fin du monde qui a commencé
d'élection en élection de plus en plus
d'abstention il me faut trois bouquins
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
le conseil soyez exigeants ne cédez rien
marcher votre chemin comme l'avait dit
vu à moi
les le niveau d'exigence de la jeune
génération et le vaccin de cette société
tant qu'ils sont là
allons demander beaucoup
on a toujours une garantie qui sans
frappe
même si pour finir cette comparaison à
mon avenir alors après les trois
bouquins pour [__] c'est trop dur là
en ce moment je suis en train de lire
hier pour faire un truc pareil
j'ai lu le traître et le néant
et puis je l'emprise
ont de fait marquant de l'effort
je suis honnêtement ce qui me détend
lancement vous avez vous [__] de moi
vériste
la véritable histoire des gracques tu
vois de la politique à rome
et saharien qui m'ont envoyé sa balle
j'adore
je suis dedans quoi est ce bon comme y'a
pas donc je immédiat hip hop cause c'est
ça me détend mais c'est rien peu à temps
qu'est-ce que j'ai regardé ses tournées
police 19 cents par m non c'est pas ça
les regarde
pas ce que je sais c'est pas moi qui
décide de la maison
je perds tout le temps
alors non mais je jeu pour être honnête
youtube netflix
comme beaucoup de gens et moi j'adore
aller regarder les films tu vois des
autres pays où des séries d autres pays
alors les turcs les trucs argent tard
je suis très fier de ça parce que c'est
d'abord ton prend un coup sur la tête
parce que tu es persuadé que nous autres
français les plus intelligents que tout
le monde a peur ça c'est pas vrai puis
leurs trucs sont plus excitant que les
nôtres fonds
non voilà et puis ces temps derniers
j'ai vu comme un peu hein
je regarde beaucoup les documentaires tu
vas sur arte sur tout ça
ea c'est ton dernier l'institut la
guerre d'algérie
j'en ai bavé la temps à des fautes a les
larmes aux yeux tu
j'étais gamin moi j'étais vraiment petit
mais bon son lagarde 1 la redevance télé
je vous
abattez envahissent cet impôt un mec si
vous supprimez ça c'est fini ça va
rentrer dans le budget on a compris qu
après on dira que tu laisses pas
raisonnable non quelqu'un fait remonter
les prix mais alors c'est sûr qu'il faut
organiser beaucoup de choses là dedans
mais mais la redevance c'est la facilité
de le supprimer c'est la facilité
par contre
je préfère vous dire que les écuries
d'augias aurait nettoyé
parce que
jean luc mélenchon merci ça y est cette
fois ci on a plus de rendez-vous à
vouloir prendre rendez-vous mais l'année
prochaine d'accords si je suis élu ça
serait marrant non
1 enfin goûter aux reviendra reviendra
ici
un épisode numéro 3 merci de m'avoir
reçu je sais pas
je sais que c'est beaucoup regardé et
pour moi c'est souvent l'occasion de
développer évidemment je vous parle à
boussens peu le défaut j'oublie qu'il ya
des gens derrière la caméra et je vous
parle à vous et
comme la relation est plutôt détendue
peut-être que je suis pas assez
rigoureux dans la démonstration parce
que je suppose que
tout cas fois ça a donné plus d'un
million de personnes qui ont regardé ce
à la fois d'avant ça a continué pendant
des mois on était à 2 2 millions et demi
celui-là aussi va sûrement traîner un
moment
évidemment que si je suis élue récemment
vu ça va être regardé dans toutes les
ambassades des coupeurs morceaux il a
dit si il a dit là qui nous a dit
c'est qui nous a dit on à qui encore
comme vrais alliés
dans l'ombre
facile
tous ceux qui ont envie d'être aussi et
non alignés qui nous oblige à nous nous
nous les français facile le tour des
pays francophones
on voit avec le moyen de faire et puis
eux
et puis
le monde l'attend vous savez une chose
dont vous le savez pas il y avait un
truc s'appelait l'union latine
machin des années 30
est plein de monde là dedans
or les allemands nous ont dit dans les
années 90 ça sert à rien pourquoi vous
gardez ça
et on l'a dit sous
bassement voilà
moi je trouve d'abord nous les français
la nation soeur ses litanies c'est
l'état donc il faut faut se mettre bien
avec les italiens
et puis à toute la méditerranée mais bon
on va recommencer les missions sur des
barres là dessus jean luc mélenchon
merci à tous merci
[Musique]
com